so a group of people who are apparently
smarter than us have this fake clock and
they said that it's now 90 seconds until
midnight and that apparently means the
world's going to end in nuclear
Annihilation and I think these guys I
shouldn't say guys because there's women
they did this big ceremony where they
like pull down the sheet they do it all
the time and they're like the clock has
moved to 90 seconds to midnight and
they're all like actually they don't say
anything they just like turn very slowly
and then stand there and don't move must
be very awkward to film but I think they
must be really excited when when war was
declared and Russia moved into Ukraine
because they were like Hey we're once
again relevant in discussing nuclear
Annihilation because for the longest
time nobody was really talking about
nuclear war and they they moved the
clock up to I think 100 seconds to
midnight which means you know the end of
the world because of climate change then
Russia does its Russia thing invades
Ukraine and I'm sure they were like oh
let's uh let's let's talk about nuclear
Annihilation so we will and I want to
give a shout out to the movie Watchmen
because one of my favorite lines ever
when Dr Manhattan the characters asked
about the the the Doomsday Clock being
moved Five Minutes to Midnight he says
it's as nourishing as a photo of oxygen
to a drowning man
and and
I guess simply put this is complete
meaningless nonsense but that being said
the us is going to be sending tanks into
Ukraine Russia's pissed Russian
propagandists are saying it's already
World War III just fire the nukes
already and uh look at that we're
talking about this again after that huge
show last night with Stephen Crowder so
we're gonna get to that but before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
directly click that join us button and
you'll get access to exclusive members
only segments of this show we had a
really awesome time with Stephen Crowder
last night we talked for a little bit
longer than normal so the episode went
up a little late but we talked about
inside baseball inner workings of
business and there's some jokes and
stuff it's really interesting if you
want to check it out go to timcast.com
join us support our work and as a member
you're helping our cultural Endeavors as
well as the work we do in reporting the
news so don't forget to also smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends take
this video share that URL whatever it's
the most powerful thing you can do
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more or is Nuance bro hey
thanks for having me uh it's cool to be
on right on what is what is Nuance bro
it's not a name is it yeah I mean it's a
YouTube channel Twitter page I haven't
made YouTube Channel videos for like
three months now but I've been doing a
lot of Twitter stuff uh spaces you were
in one of the spaces not too long ago
yeah that was cool uh by the way I
brought you guys some gifts uh if I
could give you guys oh yeah I love them
all right let's see it's kind of weird
gifts for for weird people I brought a
rubber Ducky from uh Lufthansa first
class terminal in Germany so that's
that's one of the gifts for who uh I
don't know what one of you guys I
brought uh well these are like coasters
from Iran so this is like sanctions
country so let me I I will also just say
as you're getting getting the gift I did
not know you had gifts prepared but uh
yeah they're gone right now yeah yeah
goodness they got they got dragged off
by Bears last night nothing we can do
about it uh speaking of bears tigers
this is Russian tiger ammo for AKs oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah these are a lot
harder to get these this is uh akml yeah
yeah
and then uh one more well actually you
know two more I got a Hugo ak ammo so
country that doesn't exist anymore and
then uh this is like these are like
women who are impoverished in Iran make
this sort of stuff that's a little cool
thing so yeah just some gifts for the
for the people around oh cool well we
appreciate it right on man cool cool
thanks for hanging out it's gonna be fun
we also have uh Hannah Claire she's uh
taken Luke's seat from him yeah I've
reclaimed my seat I'd like to say or won
it back from Sheamus too uh yeah I'm
Hannah Claire brimwell I'm a writer for
timcast.com I did not realize I was
sitting next to Mary Poppins over here
with a bag full of stuff oh it's a good
night I I kind of feel like you know
Serge put up that picture of Biden over
your shoulder I am feeling uncomfortable
I don't love it I have to say hey
because there was like dead wall space
because we took his stuff down yeah I
sat down he was like yeah I mean we
could try and find something else I was
like we need to replace that thing
for sure did Jessica paint it or did it
come from someone yeah Jessica's
incredibly talented and let me tell you
this one's spooky yeah it's weird well
you get to you get to have Biden over
your shoulder for there you go I
couldn't think anything else here well
we got uh Phil's hanging out because uh
so Ian is on a mission to save bocus the
cat focus is going into an for an
experimental stem cell therapy to try
and regenerate his kidneys and uh he
doesn't have much time left as most of
you know bocus is the cat
Ian uh doesn't want Focus to die neither
do I so he went on a mission they're
filming it he's bringing him to a steady
art facility for experimental stem cell
they take they take stem cells from his
blood and fat
then multiply them and put them back
into his bloodstream to repair his
kidneys that's cool fingers crossed
we're hoping for bocus uh I am Phil
Labadie uh the guy that yells in All
That Remains and I am here to uh give my
input on whatever we're talking about
tonight yeah it's fun season six
character change just go just go with it
I'm just here to make noise man we
shouldn't even have acknowledged that
they were gone I'm just pretending like
this is what we were doing the whole
time I'm here to take I'll take up the
uh anarchisty stuff for for Luke you
know we can we can dump on the FED right
sir just back press on all the buttons
yes uh a little bit of fake news I
didn't miss my flight Frontier just
delayed my flight for like nine hours
and I was stuck in the airport and uh it
was great I got to walk around an
airport it's a really lovely experience
but I'm back Kellen did a great job at
Kellen PDL you should follow him because
he really picked up the mantle and held
the torch quite well I think so yeah
right on yeah we got a bunch of other
stuff to talk about too I really want to
talk about Rick and Morty because he got
canned or whatever he got canceled so
we'll talk about Justin Island but let's
jump into this first story
because I guess it matters nuclear war
nuclear war matters the New York Times
reports Doomsday Clock moves closer to
midnight than ever the bulletin of the
atomic scientists at the clock at 90
seconds to midnight on Tuesday citing
the war in Ukraine as well as climate
change okay so both
online disinformation and other threats
what are they saying is disinformation
where they're like anything is bad we we
really want you to pay attention to our
organization anything they disagree with
or would inhibit their uh acrement of
power so so what what the main issue is
that uh Russia is there's war Russian
personalities on TV have outright said
we're in World War Three and they've
been saying it for months now it's been
going on for like six months we're in
World War Three just fire the nukes
already and we're sitting here going
like no no no nukes can't happen nukes
can't happen and I'm kind of like I
don't know man I kind of feel like they
could happen and now you have this um
this clock which is
I just I think it's the stupidest well
how long has it even existed that's
right 27. 40 so they think we're even
closer than the Cuban Missile Crisis
exactly and that's well we didn't have
disinformation then it's very important
that we count for modern day
disinformation yeah that's probably the
the big one that's uh I'm bringing the
clock closer you got to take into
consideration you know back when the
Soviets were putting nuclear missiles at
our doorstep they did not have
middle-aged fat men with Maga hats
posting memes there was no orange man to
be worried about right that's right and
then once Trump came along the clock
just went straight to like one second to
midnight they were like uh Jerome that
didn't really but uh it was at 100
seconds to midnight look here's the
point there's a legitimate point we made
that we are dangerously close to
Annihilation because psychopaths in both
parties are like Yay war and Kevin
McCarthy's wearing the lapel pin and the
handkerchief like supporting Ukraine
they all want to vote for more funding
to send over there to to instigate more
conflict more than it already is and as
much as I will say outright of course
Russia invaded Ukraine Russia's the
aggressor all that the U.S is not on the
border of Russia Russia is in a border
dispute with a border country on its
border the United States is on the other
side of the planet quite literally why
are we involved in this especially if
it's going to escalate us to World War
III yeah have you seen the ceremony that
they do when they reveal the clock
they'd have it covered and they go yeah
yeah and they just like look and they're
like yeah look how close we are you know
sick it's like you're just scared right
you just put a Time on there and they're
like you just made it up and what is the
explanation behind this like how do they
get to like 90 seconds like what fake
information that they're afraid of
versus War like today at 90 seconds here
let's let's let's play the little
ceremony for you guys oh goodness it's
funny because the members I want you to
imagine all these people like there's
five people and they're supposed to look
like academic and smart but imagine
filming this there's a voiceover and
they just stand there for a minute pull
the thing down and then stand there
again the members of the science and
Security Board move the hands of the
Doomsday Clock forward largely though
not exclusively because are they
breathing dangers in the war in Ukraine
we move the clock forward the closest it
has ever been to midnight
it is now
90 seconds to midnight I feel like
that's the title of an action movie like
there's a great song by Iron Maiden
called two minutes and look look it's
like we're not scared of that no no look
at this look at this for 20 seconds they
just stand there and do nothing as we
zoom in and they zoom in and like could
you imagine also someone made that right
that's what I was gonna say like imagine
you're you're like a a props Department
you know it's some you know for some
production company or something and you
get a phone call like can you make a
clock that signals the world is about to
end do you get in trouble if you like
leak the the time
oh no they leaked the the 90 seconds
everyone found out too early but only a
little bit of the clock because we
really got to stress that's what I was
gonna say like has it clearly this is
not the same clock since 1947 like has
it always been like the quarter has it
ever been like more than actually has it
ever gone I've never been further away
it has they probably change it to just a
quarter when when they wanted to make
the impact have more impact was there
something specific that today like we
reached 90 seconds do we reach it last
week like
if there's anything anything policy wise
but I mean I think it's a bad idea to
send Abrams Tanks to Ukraine did you
ever like hear someone count down for
their kid and be like if you don't do
something by the time I count to three
like you're in trouble and it's like one
two two and a half yeah
and the kids just like I ain't moving
I'm not yeah did they ever break it down
to like you know milliseconds at some
point where like five milliseconds away
from Midnight well because it's relative
right it's never been obviously the
clock means nothing they're saying this
and and you know like like I said like
legitimate point about the potential for
annihilation
but what happens if tomorrow Vladimir
Putin actually fires a nuke and it's a
limited and it's like it's like a
tactical nuke that blows up a military
base so nuclear war has begun are they
going to then be like it's 45 seconds to
midnight and then what happens if the
U.S retaliates with a nuclear torpedo
strike and they're like it's 44 seconds
44 seconds and they're sitting there
thinking like guys we only have 44
seconds left if if we want to up the
clock every time we get closer to
nuclear Annihilation we're gonna run out
of seconds no it's like Bitcoin you just
break it down satoshi's you know you can
always just break it down more we're
three-fourths of a second to midnight
are we gonna do milliseconds yeah yeah
so apparently when it was 17 minutes to
midnight this is what it looked like
it's like they still always when was
that what year was that uh I don't know
uh this was a 1991 okay oh right after
the uh follow the Soviet Union right
right they were like everything's fine
which was ridiculous because it's not
like there was fewer nuclear weapons
when the Soviet Union fell it was worse
yeah it was worse because it fell and
then Ukraine was like all of a sudden we
have nukes and then everyone was kind of
like uh hold on there a minute like
except for the Doomsday Clock they were
like we're doing this fine it's fine no
worries you know those nukes they left
lying around all over the place after
the collapse of the Soviet Union
actually less likely to be a problem now
despite we don't know who's controlling
them yeah the Doomsday Clock is not
afraid of that they really are afraid of
whatever Putin's doing and
disinformation I assume it America I
honestly I feel like the Doomsday Clock
is just another piece of propaganda for
uh ngos to use to try to influence
political opinions in in countries that
they don't have actual yeah they don't
that they don't have the ability to
actually influence policy other than you
know to try and get people to vote a
certain way when they watch by it when
they first uh when they first launched
it 1947 it was Seven Minutes to Midnight
and that was that for a year and then it
went to three minutes was that two
minutes hey you got your song as I don't
think it's ever been in the in the
seconds
till now 100 seconds over there wait so
it's never been more than 15 minutes so
they only had to ever do the quarter oh
wait wait I think I see 17 minutes there
yeah right that was 91. right that's
right that's right that's the farthest
we've been yep after the fallacy yeah
Soviet Union Falls nuclear missiles are
in the hands of multiple countries
nobody knows where they are Atomic
scientists are like no worries this is
fine absolutely fine you gotta admit
though it sounds really cool it does
five minutes I'm telling you this is an
action movie if the cast Castle doesn't
immediately make this a vlog I think
it's livid it probably is a movie 90
Seconds To Midnight no or five minutes
Two Minutes to Midnight
as well yeah I think it might be yeah
but what do you think what do you guys
think about what's going to happen with
Ukraine I mean it's kind of funny that
we're going on to a year into this war
and here's here's the challenge the big
news today was like they found
classified documents at Mike Pence's
house and I just was like I'm just I
don't care this is the third classified
document Scandal they shouldn't have
rated Trump so they went after abide and
I say okay fine if they're going to
write Trump they're going to raid by now
Mike pan says and I'm like just okay
just lock them up it's all of them I
don't care anymore this is just a
symptom of the fact that that Washington
is way too secret heavy they classify
everything they possibly can because
they don't want to have to answer for
whatever they don't have they don't have
to deal with with dealing with the press
or whatever
the the majority
of classified documents and this is just
a guess but I I imagine the majority of
classified documents are not actually
going to if if they were to be if the
information were to get out it's not
going to put the us at risk the majority
I think they just classify way too much
I'm just saying it's it's the the the
the clock people came out today because
they knew that there's nothing going on
yeah they're like we have our shot I
think more fun to guess
who we're not going to find classified
documents with you know what I mean like
I think Michelle Obama's gonna be fine
Kamala is going to be good there's no
there's no Michelle Obama's in trouble
they're going to find classified
documents with her because they trust
her with things but Kamala Harris they
were like you can you stay over there
there is no part of me that would be
surprised if if President Obama had
classified documents at this point yeah
with Biden in the end you know Biden
stuff since he was in the Senate and
well and then when they they when Comer
today the head of uh he's the con uh
congressman from Kentucky who's on the
head of the oversights committee and he
is requesting all of the documents the
visitor logs from the Secret Service
from when from uh Biden's house in
Wilmington from the time that he was a
vice president to for Obama to now is
the is the house in Wilmington the one
that they just found didn't they claim
that they don't have visitor logs for
that okay
New York Post this is in April uh filed
a foil across and was like please turn
over your visual logs and they're like
no no we don't keep any and now they're
saying well we don't keep visitor logs
we do keep a list of people in case
there's like a potential reason that we
need to know they just don't want to
have to answer the visitor log AKA a
visitor I don't know what you're talking
about here so it's literally the
government just doesn't want to answer
questions the more things they can that
they can classify and just say oh it's
classified just so they don't have to
just so that way they don't have to
answer it's not about any sensitive
information it's just a matter of if we
go ahead and classify it then we can we
can ignore the questions and just move
along to focus on whatever the policy
that we're trying I mean I'm a lot more
interested in why now why all these
people at the same time with these
classified documents it seems really
fishy to me uh why this is happening all
of a sudden so I'm more interested about
like the reasoning for that the
documents being found by President
Biden's AIDS by everyone all of a sudden
at the same time for like like Trump
Pence Biden you know whatever
let me pull up this story from Tim cast
Donald Trump leave him alone Trump
responds to classified documents found
at Mike's Pence's residence he never did
anything knowingly dishonest in his life
Trump took to his social media site
truth social defending the former vice
president Mike Pence is an innocent man
he never did anything knowingly
dishonest in his life with Malone I
think he's being sarcastic is that the
point I don't know so so I guarantee you
Chris Bertman wrote this story for those
just tuning in uh Diddy yeah uh yes he
did for those just tuning in
um they found documents at Mike Pence's
house and it's like okay
um
why at this point you know a nuanced Pro
is making the point how come this is
happening now with everybody Trump gets
hit he gets raided now the doj is
searching Biden's house now they're
searching Pence's house is this is like
the military finally or the doj the
executive branch some Cuda Tower they're
finally like let's just get rid of
anybody who's got any any executive
chances the president the former
president the vice president we just are
all gone they're not going to be able to
prosecute any of this stuff what
happened to Hillary when we found stuff
nothing but we weren't supposed to
nothing at all interesting right nothing
and Hillary was in no position to
declassify anything she wasn't even in
the executive branch she was well she
was a you know member statement you know
it's a good question you asked why is
this all these why does it happen to all
these people right now like why do you
think yeah well I mean did you see the
other story about the uh the FBI guy who
was leading the investigation was
quoting with Russia yeah like he leads
the Russia investigation against Trump
and then they're like oh yeah he was
we're charging him for colluding with
Russia like there's so something going
on I don't know what it is I don't know
if it's like the Deep State trying to
get rid of Biden but in like a weird way
where they're like oh but like there's
other people we're trying we're Fair
maybe trying to re-establish their uh
you know their uh their reputation with
the American public I I don't know what
it is I mean I suppose that makes sense
if the if the if the Department of
Justice was going to go ahead and say
all right let's start trying to fix our
image because we've allowed it to be
tarnished so bad and and the American
people don't trust the deal no I don't
think they would be doing it like
legitimately like this would be like the
the veil under which they say like oh
see we're hitting everybody but they
have a bigger agenda potentially at play
where maybe they're not so happy with
Biden and they want to get rid of them I
I have no idea like in that case if they
don't want bite anymore who do they want
I have some someone who can win someone
who doesn't have their wishes and
pulling out of Afghanistan maybe Newsome
I just don't know news I think newsom's
the guy is my I think Newton's the guy
that the Democrats are going to be look
look if you were a deep state cabal
conspiracy villain and you wanted
someone to fit the mold of you know like
puppet puppet Machiavellian you know
Manchurian Candidate like Newsome's your
guy I mean look at him he looks like
he's probably a lizard person you know
he's American Psycho he is American
Psycho exactly so you're sitting there
and you're like look I'm evil and trying
to rule the world this guy looks like he
fits them all he's like a young Bond
Villain Like Cloud Schwab is the old
Bond villain but like he's like the
number two you know he could be he could
be the pun villain he could do it
there's a comic book character that he
reminds me of I don't I don't remember
the comic book character's name it was a
tertiary character but it was the just
the the way that the hair was that they
kind of flew back like pointy and he
would shoot uh ice from his hands kind
of like guys I don't remember who the
guy was but
that'd be cool if if Newsom could shoot
ice from his hands I might vote for him
I mean he could fix the uh the drought
they're having in in California and club
and global warming oh okay I actually
met him when I was a kid I was a I was
at the mall in San Francisco and he's
just like sitting there on his phone and
I'm like a little kid I'm like mayor
Newsom and he's like yeah
phone I went and watched the movies for
like four hours and I come back and he's
still walking how old were you I don't
remember it was a while back but uh he
was not very nice but I met uh the other
mayor of San Francisco Willie Brown that
guy was super nice uh that was the guy
who like hooked up with Kamala Harris by
the way yeah I mean oh really yeah yeah
I mean he was he was getting it he was
he was probably in good moves he seemed
like a happy guy yeah it was probably
around that time actually maybe good for
the vice president how do you feel about
London breed how's she doing
um I feel like every day someone is I
mean listen it's San Francisco you have
to you know you go with what you get I
mean she's better than chess of Boudin
who is the AG who got recalled
um but I don't know she's still not
great she's still like she just goes
with whatever the political wins are in
San Francisco you know she was for
defunding the police then when she was
like oh that's unpopular even with San
Francisco okay no I never I never did
that that's not I didn't support that at
all so is it unpopular in San Francisco
it is yeah really like that's why they
recalled uh Chessa Boudin was Chester
Boudin with the one with uh Weather
Underground ties yeah that was the one
where his biological parents were put in
prison for like a Brinks bank robbery
back in the day and then his biological
and then his uh his uh godparents uh who
I guess raised him that raised him were
uh Bernadine Dorne and Bill Ayers who
were the founders of like yeah they're
underground but there's nothing to see
here don't worry yeah yeah don't worry
he's totally just like one of those
normal antifa communist types
so are we are we 90 seconds to midnight
because the country is going to implode
on itself no like the the well well hold
on you know don't don't jump the gun too
soon here's what I'm saying you you
asked why it was that also we're seeing
documents about Mike Pence could it be
that the political divide is inside our
uh executive branch
um so this is what I said in 2018. I was
saying that I think we're on the track
towards a Civil War and it wasn't
because one day I just said it was
because I was reading the Atlantic or
something and they were like all these
security actors around the world fear
the Civil War is possible United States
the aggregate estimate is like 35 chance
over the next 10 years and I was like
Wow and then I looked at the points they
were saying and I said with the
escalation of the of the political
conflict on the streets with the
bifurcation of world view and I'm like
yeah it seems like sooner or later this
happens and I had a bunch of
conservatives be like no it could never
happen the security state would never
allow it and then I'm like my guy
what happens when the security state is
is impacted by the very same cultural
divide and the same worldview divide
what happens when you have the DC Bureau
of the FBI very pro-democrat raid Donald
Trump and then you get a Florida Bureau
who is pissed off and so they say you
could this is this is BS so then they
say you know what we're going to file
and we're going to raid Biden's house or
somebody in Delaware does and then then
you get the DC Bureau again being like
they're going to come after Biden we're
going after Pence and it's what's
happening is inside the doj they're
going Tit for Tat back and forth with
their political enemies yeah I mean this
is an exciting interesting idea that I
would kind of hope is actually going on
Matt saibi wrote a few years ago that we
were close to this this thing he called
the arrest that I think he called it the
arrest that man phase or I don't want to
misquote Matt but he was basically
saying that he's seen in other countries
where you get to the point where two
black vehicles with government officials
they they speed Off full speed driving
and waving through the streets they both
pull up to the chief of police they both
jump out of the car and yell officer
arrested that man at each other
and that's what it feels like we're
getting to with this yeah why would the
doj go after the former president the
former vice president and the sitting
president and Hunter Biden's being
investigated too and everybody's saying
what could this be is the Deep State
trying to get rid of Joe Biden yo what
if I'll tell you this I've talked to
people who work in intelligence and and
I've had them say you got to understand
it's the same everywhere as it as it's
the same in here as it is everywhere
else I've had uh there's a guy I met
I won't say too much but a couple guys
of different intelligence agencies and
and you know
that I get emails from people and they
say hey Tim I work here let me tell you
what's going on I've met people in
person they say hey look here's where I
work here's what's happening and I'm
like why are we seeing this this heavy
bias from the doj from the FBI like why
are they arresting pro-life activists
but ignoring the protesters in front of
Brett Kavanaugh's house what I'm told
paraphrasing the gist of it is it's the
exact same the based off uh agents are
scared to speak up and actually move on
the far left because they'll get fired
they'll get canceled and there's there's
higher up elements that they believe our
walk will come after them so they're
like the Divide is the same everywhere
it's the same in here so there are a
bunch of cops who are a bunch of FBI
agents intelligence guys who are you
know pro-trump or Maga or conservative
or libertarian but they won't speak up
what if now we're actually seeing a seat
of power where the the DC Bureau I think
it's the DC Bureau of the D of the FBI
is the ones that have been really
heavy-handed went after Donald Trump
after Mar-A-Lago what if now we're
finally seeing some
FBI agents be brave and say we're gonna
go after Biden so we're going to
actually do our jobs so are you saying
it's time like it's likely that mayor
Garland will get removed I mean what is
the shift here because mayor mayor
Garland theoretically is at the center
of this idea I'm saying
my understanding is that these these
branches all operate relatively
independently like they have a there is
a centralization there's some Authority
but it's not like some dude in Omaha is
calling up DC and let him know that
they're going to go arrest a guy who is
no no like they handled on their own
they go to their their District Court
they go to the states the U.S courts and
things like that to a certain degree
they have autonomy they're expected to
operate
my understanding is that you know there
there are people who are in these
agencies or in the FBI or in the doj who
do think Biden's corrupt who do think
that Hunter by the script that they're
doing these illicit deals but no one has
the balls to do anything I don't know
maybe project Veritas got to him maybe
Mike James O'Keefe constantly saying be
brave maybe the FBI whistleblowers who
came to James O'Keefe finally started
inspiring some people at the mid-level
who are like
we're gonna go take a look at the
president's house now that being said it
was it was Biden's aides and lawyers who
discovered and then released the
documents but it very well may be the
reason they're pursuing the search is
because there are people who are finally
like I'm done with this I'm gonna start
going into it and then why does pence
get hit
I wouldn't be surprised if it's because
the corruption is it's they're now
saying okay we're going after you we're
going to one up we're going after your
guys sure and I also wondered with uh
Biden's release like if his aides are
finding them are they just trying to get
out ahead of it like it looks chaotic to
us but like was there another threatened
play where they're like well we have to
be the ones to say that we found
documents from our house I just want to
say that's the most white pilling story
that I've heard in ages I love the idea
of the government going after the
government
maybe but I don't I don't see as a white
pill moment no I want to clarify it was
Biden's team who notified the doj the
documents it was Pence's team who
notified the FBI of the documents so
maybe it's just
these guys are
I don't know so do we wait for Obama to
also be like ah as it turns out I too
have some documents like and then Bill
Clinton stands up I also have documents
and then drugs and bushes I do too and
then they all like stand together like
you know I'm smart can't take us all
that's what they're saying
they should take them all together
they're surrounding Trump even Biden is
I am Spartacus Trump's like he's got a
tear in his eyes like thank you guys and
they're like you come for one of us you
come for us all they would never defend
you look I don't know
I just think it's possible that we do
get to the point and this to me doesn't
sound like a white pill I don't think
it's a black pill either but we have to
come to a certain point where either
like I mentioned the FBI is arresting
pro-life activists in their homes yeah
ignoring protesters in front of judges
homes which is also illegal and the same
capacity of illegal protesting here's
illegal protesting here's illegal
they're only going One Direction
certainly at some point there's going to
be a guy in the FBI who's like I am done
I'm filing the paperwork you're under
arrest
yeah I mean it could also be uh
positioning for future administrations I
mean if you're in a political position
in the FBI currently under a democratic
Administration
um you know when a new Administration
comes in and they want a clean house
potentially in the executive branch and
they you know replace Ag and everything
uh or they place you know the head of
the OJ like you know
they they you could be the person being
like hey I'm the one who went after
Biden in his documents even under a
democratic Administration like I'm the
legit principled guy you can still keep
me around I don't know it there could be
something they're jumping off this
sinking ship kind of thing maybe I don't
know
yeah man look
10 years ago we had gamergate
you had a bunch of like left liberal
internet personalities
and they were called far right and all
that stuff and then you you get the the
the the the the ignition of the culture
War the culture War had been happening
to a certain degree Loosely and then
finally it like kicks off with with
gamergate and now
10 years ago
there were teenagers they were 16 years
old when this stuff was happening and
they were online and I thought it was
funny and they were on one side of the
other these people are now 26 years old
they are now the interns working at some
of these big corporations or
intelligence agencies or government or
Congressional offices or at scotus or at
scotus leaking documents
10 years from now they will be in their
mid-30s and they will be the mid to
higher level managers and in their in
your mid-30s we're talking CEOs we're
talking members of Congress we're
talking
people in state government and they are
going to be in the culture War so that
bifurcation that happened and that split
as people get older
the split is going to be hitting every
level of our of our culture government
production infrastructure and when we
get to the point where the Boomers have
let's just call it aged out
no longer voting no longer having an
impact on our society and its gen xers
holding desperately on to keep things
together sorry you got Millennials you
got gen Z and then you're gonna have the
young gen Alpha coming in to vote and
they are all going to be in in Universe
1 and universe a I watched a video where
a drag queen performed for teenagers at
high school and everyone's clapping like
this and they're wiggling little sticks
in the air and I'm like that's a
completely different Universe like the
people who watch this show the people
who are like the people who watch
crowded people watch Daily wire you know
to ignite that controversy but the
people who watch this space
would not be clapping and cheering
watching drag queens in lewd outfits
perform for children but to them they
like it it's normal I'm like two
completely different worlds well
literally there was that video of like a
little toddler like shooting his pistol
or whatever and people were like oh
you're not okay with like kids doing
drag shows but you are okay with this
you're pushing uh that was one of the
most insane discourses on Twitter that
I've seen in a lot it's like two con two
countries exist already it's just not
obvious that they have completely
separated in that example they were
calling it grooming it's like he's
teaching his son like basic gun safe
it's so crazy and when you call it when
you try to call that kind of stuff
grooming and you obfuscate the fact that
there is actual Google
obfuscate child rape but but like
there's no two ways about that like it's
not you can't say oh well it's grooming
this kid because he's showing you how to
properly handle a gun blah blah and then
be like that's not distracting from the
fact that there is actual child but this
is the thing they don't care they don't
they don't they have no moral there's
amazes for any other perspective they
don't there's a meme and it's Kyle
Rittenhouse and Greta tunberg and it
says their youth are not like our youth
and you know the funny thing about that
Meme is the left and the right both
share it in the exact same way on
ironically it's the only uniting thing
the other one is uh that there were some
15 year old who like protested a uh LGBT
Rally or something with like holding a
crucifix and the police carried him off
like he's hands feet and they put it
next to the one like we just we just
want to see what's happening here insane
I mean just the just the way that you
know I I don't want to beat a dead horse
about right now but just the way the
writtenhouse was classified is
completely insane people still talk
about Rittenhouse as if he was you know
he's he's guilty of of aggressive murder
it's it's ridiculous I mean did you see
that story this is to your earlier point
about uh that gay couple that like they
adopted yeah like so like you know
people were talking about that story and
then the reactions I saw from certain
people who you know supposedly on the
right like this is two part people in
particular but like their first reaction
no no their first reaction was to post
like oh look but here's a photo of a
little girl at a Hooters like if you're
not as like how come the people who
oppose this never talk about this it's
like if that's your first reaction is to
pull up what about ISM when a story
about a gay couple raping their adoptive
kids and again that's very sub it's rape
it's like oh we're going to get food at
Hooters and we're gonna compare it with
rape what are you talking about that's
not it's insane I wanna I wanna mention
the Hooters thing too because it's like
we talk about grooming with these people
dancing in lewd outfits for children and
it's like look man I don't think you
should bring your kids to Hooters
because it's it's like it's kind of low
brow but there's a big difference
between the women there are wearing
shirts and shorts okay that like you can
see their cleavage but women wear those
things in public all the time they walk
around doing that that that is a social
Norm that you might be like well you
know I don't like my kids around that
stuff but people do it everywhere I
would recommend not bringing your kid to
Hooters but um the fact that women have
a body shape and wear you know I don't
even want to call them skimpy I would
necessarily it's not they're wearing
bikinis or anything they're wearing
shorts and form fitting right
not appropriate for kids in my opinion
at the same time very different from a
strip show very very different from
having a drag queen strip in front of
children or having children strip for
them at a gay bar which they've been
doing or what was it literally sex
clowns like drag queens are sex clowns
that's what they are they're they're
sexualized clowns like they're they're
the whole It's Burlesque
it's like crossover between it's like
it's like LGBT burlesque yeah and you
know jenkuger put out this tweet and he
was like if I had the money I'd put on
the biggest drag show and my first
thought was like you do have the money
saying he does not that expensive I mean
you could do it for a couple Grand my
attitude is like dude I'll put on a big
drag show this'd be awesome we'll go to
local theater we'll do a big drag show
we'll get some of the best drag queens
we'll invite you know everybody will do
free food free drinks of course with the
drinks dress and drag for that 21 20
minutes
because it's for adults and uh I have no
issue with adults wanting to do
entertainment silly funny things like
this or whatever they want to do it's
the weird thing that they're going after
kids but anyway my ultimately to bring
it back to the we're talking about the
classified documents the point is two
clearly different realities and if
you've got people right now
that you were you're we're at the point
where we are actually watching these
people have children strip on stage at
gay bars this was there was a young boy
I'm not gonna say his name because his
family's litigious he's ripping his
clothes off and dancing around and
they're giving him money I'm like that's
what stripping is okay you can call go
go dancing you can call it stripping
call bikini bars whatever you want to
call it's all the same thing not not all
strip clubs are fully nude a lot of
States it's illegal to be fully nude
they have to wear bras and panties
having a little kid pops around in his
underwear for money what do you think
you're doing
there are people defending that and they
say what's wrong with it I know a guy
who's a leftist I talk to him all the
time and he said what's wrong with sex
education and I said bro we're talking
about Chicago in the project Veritas
expose I said giving kids sex toys and
Lube is not sex ed that's Kink education
sex education is like here's the
reproductive parts of the body here's
what they do here's why they do it
here's what you need to know about
safety going to a kid and being like
here's a variety of toys whips you know
cattle nine tails or whatever you look
at sick you can look at sex education
like a Chilton's book for like a a car
right sexual education is how it works
these are the body parts etc etc once
you start
describing sexual acts that sound like
you're selling a car that's different
you know it's like if you're trying to
to explain how to use use lube and stuff
like that that's that's trying to create
an Allure and and instruct kids about
pleasure and all the adult themes that
go along with sex if you're talking
about sexual education it's like you
know you can talk about the body parts
and talk about the functions and stuff
like that but to talk about you know
lube and stuff like that that's that's
enticing yeah it's enticing young adults
who are just learning about sexuality
I'm gonna make one more point on this
before we go into the next story because
I've made so many points about this but
uh you know Nuance bro have you read
this book I I'm familiar with the
genderqueer book did you read it I did
not read it but I'm familiar with what's
in it yeah um I got close to the end
I've read the whole thing so far but I
will just point out a few very important
things that people don't understand
about this book
the first thing everybody knows about
this book is that it was shown to
children and it has inappropriate images
of sexual activity among adults uh the
characters in it are in their 20s I
think at the time when they're engaging
in these activities they're showing
these explicit activities to children
and the author said in an interview it
should have been more explicit the first
thing people don't know about it which
many of you may know because you've
heard me say it Ad nauseam but I'll say
for those that aren't familiar is that
the intro to the story is this this
woman talking about her severe
psychological trauma and abuse but it's
clear she doesn't understand she was
abused by her parents made to pee in the
yard when she was three years old she
couldn't read till she was 12. she would
wear dried old crusted pads with blood
flaking off of it which went to school
and she smelled so bad she got called
into the counselor and told you need to
learn basic hygiene my question is where
are her parents her parents were abusing
her what you discover in the end of the
book she explains that what she's doing
is actually her sexual fetish she is
aroused by being perceived as a man she
says it in the book and then it's like
interesting so it would seem that the
entire thing they're teaching children
is they want you to engage in the sexual
fantasies of other adults in day-to-day
life is it isn't that called
organophilia when you're turned on by or
is it oh that only Otto androphilia is
what she calls it right so she's aroused
the thought of herself being a man yep
and
when so so you have to imagine when this
person is going around and saying call
me this call me this it's like are you
asking us to engage in your sexual
fantasy to arouse you
same thing to Phil's point if they're
giving specific descriptions of like
sexual acts as opposed to like here is
how biology Works they are making it so
that we are dominated by uh uh being
compelled to
pursue sexual desire at all times and it
begins at extremely young age and it's
all the energy it's grooming and I think
what's sad about this is like to the
story about the the couple with the boys
and this book like
they are abuse and the fact that we are
not willing to be United on the front on
the front of like abusing children in
any capacity is bad is such a red flag
for our society it's so bizarre to me
that regardless of your political belief
you can't be like yes I am 100 Against
Child Abuse that's disturbing so so
where I'll bring these things all
together and then we'll jump to uh we'll
do a hard sideway is just when we're
entering this period where you are going
to have elements of our own law
enforcement existing in either world one
or World a you know because we don't
want to put anybody second you're a
world one or world day Futurama joke
then people are going to say outright
you're gonna have a cop saying like
that's an evil person there's gonna be a
cop on the other side saying no you're
the evil person because they both see
two completely different things
that's where we're going when we get to
the point where
right now it's Millennials gen xers are
close closer together uh baby boomers
are very close together in their world
views you can even look at the political
polling from Pew going back years and
where the overlap is between Democrat
Republican and as you get into
Millennial it starts bifurcating and
then gen Z completely bifurcated what
happens when Gen Z is in their 50s and
every generation below them is Universe
one Universe a what people are going to
be fighting each other physically
there's going to be no agreement there's
going to be no overlap it's going to be
quite literally you are evil period and
that's how you get into chaos but let's
uh we'll jump into this next story so we
have this from TMZ everybody's dying to
talk about the Demar Hamlin conspiracy I
woke up hearing all this crazy news
about you know whatever and then I saw
this Demar Hamlin conspiracy theory and
I said this is the most interesting
thing I've read all day or it was in the
morning so it's like the most
interesting thing I've read the past day
so Demar Hamlin has a heart attack okay
I'm sorry he didn't hit Cardiac Arrest
cardiac he didn't have a myocardial
infarction on the field he tackles a guy
takes a hit they say was a commotion
Cardis is that what they call it
and uh now they're just saying Cardiac
Arrest they're not saying commercial
card is for whatever reason
he goes to the hospital they say you
know he's gonna make it he's fine they
post a picture of him doing a little
heart they say there he is at the
hospital apparently he returned
allegedly he returned but the problem is
when he returned he was wearing a mask
glasses and his hood is over his eyes
and there he is in the window you can't
see anything he's holding a heart and
they're like look he came back he pulls
up in a car wearing sunglasses indoors a
mask and a hood over his eyes he keep
his head down walks into the room people
surrounding him you can't see his face
they haven't been like the shielded golf
cart when he's like mobile they bring
him into a room where they film him from
behind wearing a hood waving his arms
and cheering and then the reporter's
like there it is there he is and I'm
like bro I don't know who that is well
and they show probably not Bill Clinton
they show close-ups of his mom and his
brother who are walking on the field but
we never see him right like it's so
sketchy here's the best part about it
TMZ says it's not true we called them
and asked them and they said it was him
that proves it I love that logic it's
like okay hold on I didn't see his face
you can't see his face right yeah I
think that's like that's their best
picture to prove that he was there I
think that was uh Dave Chappelle so what
do you think's going on there like if
you had to bet everything would you say
that was him or wasn't him if he had to
bet everything and not him interesting I
think I think maybe like you know after
he experiences that hit he goes to the
hospital like maybe he doesn't look so
good maybe he doesn't want people to see
like him in a disheveled State I I have
no idea but he could be like pale sweaty
gaunt and looking miserable and so
that's fair point I mean I I don't see
any incentive for his family to to lie
about his attendance there like for for
what he's not playing games anymore he's
not in the eye of the public his cue
writing whatever you want to call it not
that it was like particularly High to
begin with but it exists right so this
is basically like what's your level of
popularity among the public he's out
he's injured he's done this is on your
career I know skateboarders who are on
the verge of turning pro and they sprain
their ankle knock him out for three
months and they get dropped by every
company so here's a guy who is knocked
out of the press no one's talking about
him they're like we need to get him back
out there and I can certainly imagine an
agent coming in and being like look man
I know you're hurt we gotta get you back
out there and get some cameras and get
some press attention so that you don't
lose the news cycle what can we do we
can't leave the hospital I said let's
just get a guy put a mask on sunglasses
we'll do a quick appearance we'll say
it's you no one will know it'll never
prove it that that that to me makes a
lot of sense what people think is that
Demar died and the vaccines did it I
think he's dead I think the vaccine did
it they think they run a body double
which makes no sense I don't want that
to be true
if he died from a heart attack they
would just say guys he died from a heart
attack right we all know he had a heart
attack
yeah I don't know I think he's probably
not in good shape and I think he's that
I don't think that was him it's too
weird why wouldn't you just show his
face at any point even his eyes he might
look like I don't know he's got a
hood on and a mouth you can't show his
eyes at all like they did not show this
person like Islam stuff sure it's better
than nothing right I can't he shows up
in the cup what gets me is like they
brought his mom and younger brother
who's like a little kid out like it is
weird like why wouldn't I don't have it
with him I don't have an opinion on
whether it is or is not him but it is
super weird to be like we can't come up
with any clear pictures that actually
identify this as the guy we're saying
like just take our word for it that's
super weird like they could have just
just as easily like taken a picture of
him in the booth or like in the whatever
that's called the box I'm super into
sports as you can tell uh in the box and
been like oh yeah look he's here with
the head coach or the guy who owns this
whatever
he looks like crap he doesn't
then why show up why would they film in
the booth from behind of him waving his
arms in the air instead of just doing
nothing but if it's what you're saying
like I do think that's a much higher
risk strategy because if they find out
it's some body double or whatever like
that would just be no no no no no that
would be huge that would be amazing this
conspiracy theory right now is press so
at the very first at the very least he
might have been thinking like yeah I'm
gonna come back and check out the game
and hang out in the box and they were
like did you shoot you do wear a mask
and sunglasses get everybody going crazy
think it's a conspiracy that is also a
possibility because I mean that seems
more plausible I would say like that one
than like the body double thing but it's
like look at this picture of him his
hood is over his eyes he's not even
looking at the at the field why is he
throwing the rock up like is he a JC fan
he's doing a heart but but hold on Mason
uh why is he that was a terrible people
posted the picture where it's the
Illuminati but hold on why you see his
hood is over his eyes he's not looking
at any thing what is going on he's not
even looking at the field he's like like
someone told him hey stand by the window
and do a sign there and take a picture
it's like okay I can't see so I'll do it
right here is this good that makes no
sense what's he he's just an angle thing
he's like looking down like this it's
over oh come on dude his eyes are
completely covered with the hood you can
see that it's not him there's no way
I'm gonna say it I'm gonna say it's him
taking a safe ride here yeah I just
don't understand why they can't okay why
they wouldn't come up with a decent and
also we're at a casino and you walk up
to the Demar Hamlin is it him table and
there's it is and it isn't you're
putting your chips on the it's him yeah
wow yeah because that's why I asked you
the question but here's you know you
know why I wouldn't because there's no
proof to suggest it is there's no
evidence his family saying it is
um his family never said it was sorry
he's locked on the field I'm a
journalist he said they contacted them I
I made a phone call it's Bill Clinton
his family said it you heard his family
actually come out and say it happened
because all I know is that TMZ said we
made a phone call and they confirmed it
I'm like I shouldn't say that but like
I assumed from that press release they
contacted the bills or whatever team he
plays for you know then they were like
yes indeed we brought him back like they
didn't say we talked to his mom they
didn't say we talked to his uncle like
they they didn't say anything they just
said yes someone has confirmed it was
him like this is so weirdly non-specific
if it was specific and to your point
like if he felt awful if he didn't look
good like why not just be like yeah he's
not back yet but he's watching the game
from home he's having a good time like
yeah why why bring him out there if he
is in a position where he looks so
terrible he doesn't want to be seen like
you must mean that he also feels awful
and we're gonna drag him to a football
stadium like that seems cruel or
desperate or maybe he wanted to be there
I don't know look look watch this video
anyone to know watch this video looks
like Jamar Hamlin is on watch yes if
they show him in the stadium in any
capacity it will blow the doors off of
this place Demar Hamlin just showed up
and it looks like his mom mom and his
little brother is there oh we love to
see it stay tuned it's the Bengals so
yeah we saw no one we saw nothing coming
up on CBS also he says it if they show
him in any capacity there's like
foreshadowing
[Applause]
no okay
what's happening he's wearing sunglasses
his head is down he's got a hood and a
mask on I just why why
and then he just go no stopping no
looking no waving nothing just Zip Zip
there's more there's more
this mom McDermott telling us it was so
good to have him around he told us it's
baby steps right now
how involved he wants to be every day a
spokesperson close to the family said
despite being out of the hospital he
still has a lengthy recovery he requires
oxygen and he has his heart rate monitor
regularly but he is upbeat he's positive
yeah if he requires oxygen there's
nothing in the room do you see oxygen
there I don't right here what a scene oh
I mean why are they filming this
why did they film him from behind in the
room waving his arms like this you can't
see his face it's look at this can
this is an SNL skin
any of this by the way I'm just going
based off what you guys are talking
about my thoughts have suddenly shifted
I mean when he's doing the arm thing now
I'm like wait if he was in truly bad
shape we need to be able to do that
wouldn't he be winded like also why
don't you pull your hood back for God's
sake well they also just said he
requires auction I don't see oxygen yeah
exactly Somebody explain to me maybe
it's going on maybe it's like through
the clothing he has a backpack we can't
see that's scary look at his hood over
his eyes he's not looking at anything I
love this story he might as well be
wearing them
it's just weird here you can see it's
actually Kanye West but like it's Kanye
West why film this video This Way like
they film it from the side from behind
so that little kid is not his brother
unless he's a kid I don't know about
which is totally possible like he's in
there alone without the people we
brought out as his mom and brother yeah
somebody explained to me what's going on
I don't know that's the one they said
or something so this tweet this guy said
my thought is that is no longer with us
I don't know about that because that
didn't make sense either it would make
no sense to have him come out if he
wasn't around like if he died in the
hospital did you feel like he died yeah
yeah it actually would make more sense
they would say it was commercial Cardis
he took a hit to the heart we tried to
save him we couldn't and then having him
come out and say he's on oxygen and all
this stuff is actually like more suspect
yeah so I don't think he's dead I don't
just like I think he's really sick and
that's sad if we shouldn't like use a
fake person as a puppet to advance The
Narrative of what the Bengals like I
don't have any proof that that's not him
there's no part of me that would be in
any way surprised if I found out that
that was definitely not him like there
is this guy is so sick he requires
oxygen his mom isn't even sitting with
him in this shot like are you what they
put no effort into actually making them
seem like he's simulation man
everything's fake he's also wearing
bright red he's the only person they're
like please notice exactly who's walking
through the crowd right now like it's
think about this think about this when
you wear your Bulls the journalists have
provided no evidence Bill's colors that
he was actually there other than that's
what they claim and I'm like okay well
for me that's fine you claim whatever
you want but I don't believe it uh right
like you know I need I need something
more than just be like he was there
trust me see here's a picture of a guy
in a jacket I'm like I don't know who
that guy is yeah that could be Bill
Clinton for all I know probably not Bill
Clinton because he'll be waving his arms
around like that he's old man but that
could be anybody so if they came and
said no we got a photo even if they did
that even if they're like here's a photo
of him smiling with fans I'd be like oh
okay well you know they didn't film it
but I'll take I'll take them exactly
like I wouldn't have been surprised if
he was in the box with the owner of the
team right oh and the wife and the kids
were someone Super Chat the wife and the
kid weren't even with him when when the
when the when the brother or the mom
walked in I'm sorry that's why the kid
the brother and the Mom they're not with
him they're walking in the different
like I said like oh yeah also your son
is so sick he requires oxygen we're
bringing him to a game and like I don't
know who that little kid is but it's
definitely not his brother like here's
the thing consider this for the media
the media can come out and say and they
will
Demar Hamlin showed up he was there
regular people will hear that and be
like oh did you hear he's out of the
hospital he's there and then you'll be
like bro did you watch the video no yeah
that was that didn't look like him I
don't know the media said that it was
him so it was
a twin we don't know about maybe that
that point is it was a twin they would
not have covered his face yeah I don't
know man maybe he doesn't look enough
like him there he's like a scar from
like a the fraternal twins like they're
both boys but they don't look like at
all they're not it's a guy whose name is
DeMar Hamlin but it's a totally
different guy
so it's like technically yeah we were
not lying to you that is Damar Hammond
just not the football player he's a
dentist from Dubuque did you see that
there's another Super Chat in there that
said that he posted Tim look at his
Twitter he posted clone did you see that
he didn't posted clone he posted the
word clone apparently I can't fact check
it so if someone should look it up real
quickly but if if he posted that that
makes it even weirder I really hope uh
I really hope that's true yeah that'd be
wild Your Voice Sounds like a car idling
to me sometimes it's so low oh yeah he
did yeah yo hey come on man what what
wait what is this is that supposed to be
is that him so there's a painting of him
some dude whose face you can't see and
it says clone yeah what's with this oh
this there's so much obfuscation of his
face yeah so he's probably making fun of
the idea being like people think it's
like a clone of me or something but he's
still he's admitting that it was not him
no I think he's making fun of the idea
like this is a picture I guess I guess
but where is his oxygen yeah
well I continue to obfuscate your face
like that though too I mean he's
generating press for himself I mean why
did why did you do that you know it's a
good point good point he's gen he's
generating pressure himself the fact
that we're talking about it yeah like a
mostly overtly yeah political show
yeah I mean it's a fun thought process I
I think this is weird but all right so I
don't know what he looks like but it the
picture if you zoom in you could and you
knew what he looked like you would be
able to identify him right I don't know
what he looks like but if you zoom in on
that and you knew like you were familiar
with what he looked like you could be
like yes that is him no that's not
like if that was someone that I knew
like if that was like James Hetfield's
face or like you know whatever Michael
Jordan's face or whatever I could
probably be like all right I I'm I'm
familiar with the shape of the eyes and
the nose if you are alive and well why
is this the photo you post at your job I
mean I I don't know that I can answer
questions like that I'm just saying that
even though that isn't the most I'm
willing to be wrong on this front I just
don't think I am you know Fair fine yeah
I mean it kind of feels like this
painting or whatever on the brick is
like in memoriam you know what I mean
hmm like when they do those paintings
they put it up you can't even see his
tattoos that's the other thing where are
these identifying markers maybe it's
winter I'm sure it's snowing but still
still it was it was actually pretty
intense in Buffalo but I don't
understand sunglasses and a snowstorm
indoors yeah
yes like I don't know unless his eye
I know it's snowing really rough but
then what if
your press appearance oh man and not
with you I don't know we'll we'll we'll
talk about a bit more in the Super Chips
I guess we'll figure it out and we'll
talk about more but we'll just talk
about some uh some other stuff for now
let's jump to this story this is uh
I don't even I just want to talk about
it it's like not the most important or
political thing but apparently right
before the show we saw this tweet from
um
Rick and Morty Adult Swim retweeted they
said Adult Swim has ended its
association with Justin Roiland Rick and
Morty will continue the talented and
dedicated crew are hard at work on
season seven now I know a lot of people
I don't care about Rick and Morty or
whatever it's a show you might like it
or not but apparently this is they're
canceling the guy who does the voices of
the two main characters on the show but
keeping the show because he got accused
of domestic abuse is that what it is yep
domestic abuse and then what's what's
imprisonment yeah what tell me what
happened what is this story I don't know
everything exactly but apparently he had
like a domestic abuse a domestic uh
disturbance and then they call it and
then he was uh the I think his
girlfriend at the time or girl that was
involved in the situation called the
police and he was like keeping her
inside of a bathroom and then he got
charged with both domestic abuse and he
also got charged with uh let's see like
uh I think false imprisonment this
article says one failing count of
domestic battery with corporal injury
and one felony count of false
Improvement by Menace violence fraud and
or deceit notice but these are charges
these aren't even this happened on
January 19th 2020. right so this is the
important thing there's a couple reasons
why I think this is interesting one how
do you cancel the like the voice of
the guy but keep the show but he this is
a guy who's being charged he has not
been convicted
you know how do you how do you handle
something like that and this happened 20
or in 2020 two years ago three three
years ago three years ago January did he
just get Char he just recently got
charged and and this is yeah it looks
like the criminal complaint uh so
reaching the media last week so I don't
know if that means that the woman who's
unidentified she's being identified as
Jane Doe came forward later and they've
just been compiling it or what he
resigned from his game squanch games
like January 16th right there so he knew
this was coming so obviously this has
been under investigation for a little
bit yeah that's crazy this is how it
usually always goes though right with uh
like it you usually don't wait until
conviction to remove someone from their
position like you know police
departments put people on leave when
they're you know investigating I
remember like with Chris Hardwick during
like the me too stuff that was wrong
though yeah I agree but at the same time
like that's usually how it goes is they
that's they don't wait until like a
conviction or anything like that that's
kind of what I'm what I'm thinking about
this story I mean aside from the fact
that it's very weird they're going to be
like what are they gonna do replace the
the voices and you're going to get like
a weird Rick and Morty they don't sound
the same and it's gonna be a weird show
like he does the jokes here's what makes
it funny but yeah we went through this
with me too when it was hard work he was
falsely accused they took him off his
show and then finally they're like oops
then you had Aziz Ansari who was accused
of having a bad date yeah that was
amazing she was like I had a bad date
and then everyone was trying to cancel
this guy and it's like now Justin
Roiland look maybe he did it if he did
then he should he should get you know
yeah I feel like it's gonna be hard
until they release some more information
so they're saying like body cams from
the police all the details are being
withheld from the public uh pending a
protective order he also there's a
protective order in place against like
for for the victim so he's not allowed
to come within 100 feet of this person
through October 2023. so it seems like
there's obviously been some steps taken
in between but you're totally right like
it's hard to know what exactly is
happening and of course anyone is
Presumed Innocent the complaint alleges
that he did willfully and unlawfully
inflict corporal injury resulting in a
traumatic condition Upon A Jane Doe who
was in a dating relationship they said
that he did unlawfully violate the
personal Liberty of Jane Doe by violence
Menace fraud and deceit yeah what does
that mean he pleaded not guilty in 2020.
so he was charged a long time ago yeah
yeah yeah this is crazy about it he was
released in August of 2020 in a
statement they said it's hard to
overstate how inaccurate the recent
media coverage in the situation has been
to be clear not only is just an innocent
but we also have every expectation that
this matter is on a course to be
dismissed once the DA's office has
completed its methodical review of The
Evidence we look forward to clearing
Justin's name and helping him move
forward as swiftly as possible so what
do you think false false accusation well
I mean if he's already if they if
they're looking for him to be exonerated
that's what they said right they expect
to they expect this missile just ought
to be dismissed well I mean it's a bold
statement yeah dismissals like just you
know it's all not a real not a real
thing and he's already lost his job
because of it wow man I mean okay there
are one of the most popular shows that
adult swims produce in the past at least
10 years one of the most popular shows
IMDb top 100 or whatever yeah of all
time ever yeah
I mean the the show's over
they're not going to get someone that's
going to be he's the brains behind it
they're not going to be able to I mean
it's like trying to do South Park
without without trying Matt Stone and
Trey yeah yeah I mean or does it just
like
you know we have a couple missed seasons
and then eventually they bring it back
with sort of a semi-change title I don't
know there are some states where like
you can be charged with kidnapping like
if surgery is right like he locked his
girlfriend in the bathroom I was like
you're not allowed to leave they're
they're having some obviously bad
argument right like they can some states
will say like you're violating her
um
her I forgot which one it is but it's
one of her uh constitutional rights like
her right to free movement you're you're
restricting her so it may not be like
he's a crazy psycho but this obviously
could have been a very bad holistic
situation and that to me would come to
like if it goes to court if it goes
trial if he gets exonerated like there's
a chance that Adult Swim swim could like
hold back for a couple years and then be
like okay we'll release like a movie
back up we can't function in society if
someone can accuse you of something and
then before anything's been proven they
just say like okay you're removed from
your job and we're destroying this
portion of the economy that was what I
don't mean like the entirety of the
global economy I'm saying like this
element of economic activity everyone's
job at Rick and Morty it's not just one
guy yeah everybody loses their job now
because of the accusation now again if
he if it's a legitimate accusation then
he then so be it dude gets locked up but
the fact that it's not proven yet he's
denying it they're saying out right it
will be dismissed well okay that needs
to be adjudicated we need we need to go
through that without to jury or whatever
but the fact that they would be like
nope the punishment has been handed down
yeah we're it's it's it's reminiscent of
the metoo BS yeah that was the problem
with me too was that well we mentioned
the season sorry like that was kind of
like the last the last time that I heard
a lot of noise about it because people
realize that a lot of the people that
had stuff that was legitimate that were
actually going to come forward had come
forward like all the people that had
that that were inspired by me too like
they if they had the courage to come
forward they did it in the beginning if
they if they were legitimately uh you
know
assaulted or whatever and they didn't
come out in the beginning it wasn't
likely they were going to come out after
six months or whatever and so the people
that were coming out you know later you
know the later days of of of me too
tended to be the people that were like
complaining about in season sorry who
had a bad day and there was uh other
people but like that was the piece it
was hilarious it's a bad date no my
favorite response to that was like
someone being like like where are that
girl's friends being like why are why
are you putting yourself in the scenario
like you don't have to do this like it
was such a weird story all around and I
think it like it took like me too is so
complicated and of course people who are
truly me too is complicated the Aziz and
sorry stories and the fact that someone
would be like I am also a part of you
know potentially like you know people
who are really abused like that tells
you how delusional this can get like
people want to be recognized as victims
and think they have something to gain in
this case like I totally with him it's
crazy that there is like a whole studio
of people who are basically out of a job
because of this and I
feel like the only way for anyone to
know is for it to go to trial which
those articles last forever I don't
think that it doesn't matter if it goes
to trial I think that the people that
have already decided that he's guilty
they're gonna all they're always going
to believe that exactly right like it's
all gonna hang on so but like for my
position is like if he gets like I was
on pop culture once and we were talking
about Mike Tyson Mike Tyson's been
convicted of rape and someone was like I
can't believe you'd say that you're like
no it's it's legitimate that that's
that's proven fact and I know the
justice system is not something we can
always trust right in this country but
theoretically like even if the Press
never goes away that's actually this
person's best shot like at least he
would be able to point to something
right now it's just rumor your your
point about the justice system is true
it's not it's imperfect but we as a
society we have to act like we have
faith in it or else that's going to have
significant it's it's significantly
worse to to believe that your justice
system can't be trusted and that's
honestly that's that's probably the
added attitude of a lot more people than
is healthy for society right now yeah
yeah you ever see a Mike Tyson's
comments about that case by the way real
quick where did you where did you hear
the bathroom things I can't find that
anywhere I don't know this is and this
is an issue report this is gonna be like
about a week ago when everyone was first
hearing about the story because again
it's been like since 2020 and it's only
really broke as of like maybe a week ago
I heard uh I think it was like I don't
even remember who was watching but yeah
sorry man what you were saying oh no I
was just saying Mike Tyson's comments
about like the the rape case or whatever
whenever it's brought up he gets really
pissed and he's like no I he's like he
didn't rape her but he said he should
have
he got convicted right you did yeah you
did yeah that's what it's probably what
his thought process is saying that awful
awful line
he's like how old's he know 60 years by
he's like dude I'm done nobody's gonna
do anything he didn't have sort of law
order SVU like he's clearly bounced back
from this conviction yeah and he'll
punch you in the face and knock your
head right off yeah well don't bring him
on the show and I'll be okay he has that
quote where he says that not enough
people are getting hit or whatever or
something like that yeah it's like well
you know I understand the point he's
saying like it's kind of good people
aren't beating each other up but his
point is that uh actually Taylor Swift
has the has the quote say it uh on the
streets it's a knockout say it in a
tweet it's a Kappa you know she she said
it better than than uh Mike Tyson if you
ask me she has a way with words yeah and
then she throws her phone in the video
but she makes a point like they'll go
online people will say these awful
things they won't say it in real life
because they'll be scared about what the
consequences will be freedom of speech
doesn't mean freedom from consequences
true that's right it's true
yeah but I don't know man I I don't I
don't think it's going to be like a
Resurgence of me too or anything no I
don't know the whole believable women
thing I don't know where that's at I
wonder if they're gonna like have they
have like recordings of him already and
that's the name of their finishing
season seven and they're gonna release
it oh they're gonna put they're gonna
use an AI to make his voice that's the
other thing how bad is that gonna be
remember you guys remember can they just
cut the audio from previous there's been
like a bunch of seasons of the show
right they wouldn't do that but you
remember the Joe Rogan voice yep oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay they they they
had a AI analyze Joe Rogan's voice and
they made a thing where you can type in
words and it would say it as Joe Rogan
they'll do that with him I hate
technology that's so creepy yeah you're
gonna be watching him to be like this is
a robot
the the jokes won't have the oomph yeah
for sure because he does the voices and
then does he write the show too or yeah
presumably right I believe so he's like
the spine of this entire thing yeah he's
a show he's Seth MacFarlane yeah exactly
exactly I mean after this like if he
does get proven innocent does he start a
new show oh he's done he's done forever
look man people like him people like
Justin Roiland he's tweeted he tweeted
some anti-woke thing a while ago and
then he deleted it I can't remember
exactly what it was but this is the
point I want to make to everybody
they come for you
um look maybe he's guilty that's if he's
guilty then so be it if he's not guilty
when this all ends and the courts say
Okay case dismissed you ain't get your
job back they're not gonna let you back
in those doors you're done
you should have spoken out and set your
foundation before it was too late now
look I don't blame the guy who seems
mostly apolitical for not realizing the
culture was you know getting to this
point but I'll say to everybody else
because I hear it from people all too
often look I'm trying to keep my head
down and then hopefully like nobody will
come and give me grief it's like oh come
on dude here's what happens you got
arroa houses and they're going door to
door and you think if you turn your
lights off they ignore your house bro
they're going door to door it's it's
going to come to you no matter what you
can speak up now and and Link arms
figuratively with all the people who
agree and tell these people to shut up
or you can duck turn your lights off and
then wait until they come to your house
smash your windows and then burn
everything down yep there and there
there is no there is no way to be like
Oh I'm just not gonna get involved when
it comes to when it comes to
the culture War if someone makes an
accusation you're in whether you like it
or not someone says something about you
you you're in the culture War someone
that that on one side of the culture War
decides they don't like something you
did they make an accusation you're in it
you don't get to opt out there is no
more oh I just stay out of politics that
doesn't happen with a culture let's talk
about politics we have the story from
timcast Vermont Supreme Court supports
allowing illegal non-residents to vote
the Court ruled the state's constitution
does not require voters to be citizen to
take part in local elections by Hannah
Claire bermolo so what's going on told
you I was a writeration writer what's
the story you you tell me so in 2018
Montpelier and another town whose name I
can't actually pronounce winisco I think
it's pronounced they passed ordinances
saying anyone can vote in our municipal
election so local elections they can't
vote at the state level they can't vote
at Federal but it means that you don't
need to legally be a resident of Vermont
you don't need to legally be an American
citizen to take part in these local
elections and they say said you know
it's good it encourages people to
participate if you're being represented
by these local governments you should
get to vote and it was uh in 2020 the
state legislator approved the they had
to change their Municipal Charters to
approve this and it was sued the RNC
sued in April of 2021 and said this is
crazy like voters shouldn't just be able
to come from anywhere and it's a
degradation to the Integrity of
Elections and it went through a couple
different
um different rulings but basically the
Supreme Court has upheld a ruling by a
lower court saying the Vermont
Constitution uh does say that you have
to be an American citizen to vote in
state elections but does not place that
requirement on Municipal elections so
this makes uh these two cities in
Vermont there's a bunch in Maryland in
New York City uh examples of places
where you don't have to be an American
citizen to participate in local
elections so I'm not a signatory on
Phil's bank accounts but I have the
right to vote where that money goes so
I'm going to vote it to me
yeah it also has non-residents so it's
it's not just illegals but non-residents
people don't even live there no so I
mean like you could be from a different
state and hop in there for a day and
vote is that what they're saying like
they have not defined I couldn't mind
any examples of how clearly they've
defined what their residency policy is
like do you have an address if I have a
house out of state but I have like a
vacation house there I can vote in their
local level so imagine a question so
what's the population of the smallest
town in Vermont that's allowing this uh
it they're similar sizes so they're
considered one of the uh the outlets I
was reading about this say that the most
diverse cities in Vermont one has eight
thousand people one has seven thousand
so imagine if they have a like they have
an election and then like 14 000 people
show up yeah in a population of seven
thousand yeah that I guess that's
technically possible now that's pretty
funny yeah they have opened the doors to
just not requiring anything I mean this
is similar to the states that don't want
to require ID laws is that still does
that does that mean it's still a felony
if you vote in two places I guess it
doesn't it in these towns it doesn't
seem like they care I could not find any
specific like well you can't you know be
over here you can whatever uh it would
be a felony if if I am a person a
non-american citizen I guess I live in
this town I decide to build a little
collection if I then fill out the
ballots for state or uh Federal it would
be illegal right and so this is one of
the objections that the RNC has raised
they're saying like and similar uh
arguments came up when New York decided
to pass this they're saying like how do
you prevent voter fraud because we're
gonna have to print special ballots for
people who only are voting in the local
election and that's difficult and it's
more complicated now we have these other
ballots and we have some ballot like if
if I give you a ballot you're like hey I
live here and I want to vote and they're
like cool just only only fill out the
local spot and you don't understand you
check everything like is that your fault
is a terrible idea right to jail back to
jail it sounds like an awful idea
um I mean for representation these
people are the joke the joke I was
making about your bank account is that
if you allow non-citizens to vote they
will vote in the interests of the
non-citizens and not the citizens so if
you live in a small town that has a gold
mine within in the center of it that is
used to fund the medical care people are
going to be like oh I can vote here I
vote I get the gold I want to order
pizza they will why wouldn't they well
not even non-citizens I mean if this is
true
you know to be fair this is kind of how
elections used to work like in 1876 what
was the South Carolina like South
Carolina uh when it was going for haze
or whatever uh they had like what 101
turnout like for eligible voters or
whatever and like in the in the counties
along the the border with Georgia it was
like twenty six hundred percent like
yeah
if it's like 101 I go that'll look like
then you've got an issue of check the
voter rolls how does this make sense
2600 is outright like despite nonsense
levels of you know fun house World non
garbage house
yeah at that point it's just like okay
we're in we're in you know Banana
Republic territory at 2600 yeah there
are some states that like specifically
say no no matter what you have to be an
American citizen to vote here so like
Ohio is one of them I feel like that
should it should not be you shouldn't
have to say it yeah it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be a a controversial take to
say the people that vote in the states
should be residents of those States they
should be citizens of those States they
should be citizens of the United States
of America just wait the next big thing
will be nativist they'll say you're a
nativist they already say it well yeah
there's already there's already a lot of
people that that if you that have
demonized the term nationalist because
of the association with uh you know
National Socialist or whatever you know
if you are a nationalist they associate
you with with fascist because fascism is
always a nationalist kind of idea
they're gonna they're gonna shift from
white supremacist bigot or whatever to
nativist at some point and they're going
to be like it's going to be 10 20 years
and there's going to be a supreme court
battle and they're going to be like
these nativist begets think that only
people who live in some location can
vote on the rules that makes no sense
well everyone gets to say we're all
equal they're gonna win people over by
saying like if if you live here in your
green card holder right like I may not
be super familiar with this but like if
you're not allowed to vote but you do
live in the country right you do have
some sort of legal status here shouldn't
you be able to participate in local
elections right but then if they also
don't require you to show any proof of
residency or legal status then there is
no way to say who is actually partaking
in these elections and at that point you
don't really know what's influencing
these serious countries I mean Vermont
is a beautiful place obviously it's not
the population of New York City New York
City this becomes an even bigger issue
uh but I to me this doesn't this feels
like common sense like you're saying
like American citizens should vote but
we know that the idea the idea that you
have to show ID when you go to vote is
actually a controversial issue in a lot
of places they feel like you shouldn't
have to I want to push back on that it's
not actually controversial it is only
controversial if you listen to
politicians in from the Democrats the
average American citizen does not
believe that you should be allowed to
vote if you're not a citizen of the
state sure but they elect politicians
who are okay with the policies well they
they so you're complicit in supporting
it I have other issues with voting as
well as this one but you know the the
the idea that it is popular in the
United States I don't think that that's
possible did you confirm this
non-resident part you sure it's just not
like non-citizen I went through the
charter and I can't find like any they
have to register and be on the voter
rolls right like so you can't just like
show up election day and be like oh I
live in this neighboring County or
something I mean when I read it the last
time I checked the actual uh like
Charter change they weren't requiring
proof ID right so like they are saying
like you come you vote that's cool they
might have updated it in the foreign
initially passed in 2018 right so they
might have updated it since but there is
no discussion of proving residency in
the Supreme Court case or in the
original uh uh so it's like resident
honor System like you're supposed to be
a resident but we don't actually know if
you are yeah
so you could argue if that's the case
they are technically allowing
non-residents although I think it'd be
important we fact check that one yeah
yeah I mean like I said there is no
check but I'm happy to fact check it
yeah because like what are they actually
saying if there's no check it may as
well be anyone can vote if they feel
like it they're saying that for locals
elections it doesn't matter that the
Vermont Constitution does not have a say
over local elections Vermont can
regulate who gets to vote in state
elections and of course the federal
government regulates who can vote in
federal elections but they're saying
that the Vermont government doesn't have
a say over
who the municipalities are okay with
voting
no it just sounds like the end of the
country you know you see it in San
Francisco and New York they've had the
big move to allow non-citizens to vote
it's just like then then what do you
mean it doesn't I I don't understand
why your average resident or or citizen
of these of the states are okay with it
I it it just doesn't make any sense to
me I feel like mostly it's they don't
realize I really think most people don't
pay very close attention to politics
even the people that go and vote
regularly don't pay nearly the attention
that to politics that people like us do
and so for the most part they don't know
what is what laws are being passed uh in
you know in their local areas yeah and
they always start with the safest thing
too I think they started initially with
school board so they're like well you
know if you're kids they're maybe they
were born here they're American citizens
they're going to school and you might be
an illegal parent like you should be
able to have a say in your kids
education like they kind of like pull up
your heartstrings that way and then they
expand it from there and incrementalism
yeah that's how it goes yeah and then
eventually there's no country left yeah
100 that there's no there's no part of
me that doesn't believe that they're
there are people motivated to change the
fundamental structure of the United
States like and the people that say oh
no there are there are no people that
want to change the the structure of the
U.S like they're just not listening to
the writers at Vox the writers have like
there's Ian millhauser wants to get rid
of the whole Senate right there's no
reason to have a senate because
something right because there's popular
election of the of the states there's
consistently talk from people on the
left about expanding the Supreme Court
uh there's a talk about getting rid of
the Electoral College these people
do not like the the structure of the
government they don't like a limited
government they don't like a government
that puts the the individual as
Sovereign these are things that
Libertarians are constantly screaming
about Luke would be here you know
putting his hand up right along with me
these people want the federal government
to have all the authority and it's
likely that they're they're in bed with
International interests it's been it's
been a move for a really long time to
strip away the local power the 17th
amendment I think was a huge mistake I
remember reading about this I think it
was uh Ben sass who called for repealing
it this is the amendment that gave uh
the the right to elect a senator to the
popular vote in the state all that does
is erode local elections and local
involvement and that was the most
destructive thing to this one of the
most destructive things in this country
because it used to be you voted in your
local elections you knew who your state
reps were they would then go the state
senators I believe would appoint a state
a senator to go to the federal
government the idea was Senators
represent States
members of Congress represent the people
yep and there was a reason for the
distinction with the popular vote now
it's just doing the same thing and
people don't even know who their local
reps are and they're like I have no idea
what that did was made it impossible or
extremely difficult to have a Convention
of states and actually work on the
Constitution amend it For The Better or
For Worse because now people don't even
know I don't know who's your vote who's
your local rep who's your State Rep you
have any idea and these the one of the
things that I find incredibly
frustrating is to your point people
don't know you and people are completely
unaware of who represents them they have
no idea uh who their congressperson is
they have no idea who their Senator is
um they don't know who the the senior
senator is the junior Senator is but
these people feel extremely motivated
every four years to go and vote they
don't know who they're voting for they
don't know why they're voting they don't
know the policies of the people that
they're voting for but every time some
celebrity gets on TV and tells them go
vote they're oh we got to get out there
and vote for what I I have no idea
they're completely ignorant I just read
a story today about how Seattle's
running out of space for all the dead
bodies from fentanyl that's gross and
then I just got mad and I'm like why is
it that all of the the major cities are
run by democrats and are collapsing are
crime ridden
there there was a report I think the
Washington Post per capita crime top 10
cities all Democrat despite the fact
that there's a there was a couple
republican-run cities that were in the
top uh population didn't have crime or
the crime was substantially lower why is
it is because Republicans are fascists
who go around arresting everybody is it
because Democrats are extremists who at
least other prisoners there may be some
other correlating factors there I think
like what uh I mean for example of the
top cities that you're mentioning I
think like most of them have like very
heavy black populations don't they like
New Orleans Detroit no all the major
cities uh well of the ones that have
like no not exactly I'm trying to think
like if like San Diego does like what's
the like does San Diego have a super
heavy black population
um
this I bet it's comparable how high is
Phoenix Arizona uh
let me let me look up uh
San Diego is
it looks it's around 10 no oh it's not
was it five percent
what's the correlation
what do you mean like you're saying
these cities have so I mean it's like
the it's not it's not like totally
linear but like again these cities do
have like you know like the demographic
that commits the highest amount of
murders is like young black males if you
have a lot of that that's probably going
to be that that's that's a factor that's
a I mean does it correlate more than
having a Democrat mayor probably I would
say so because there's cities with
Democrat mayors that don't have
exorbitantly high San Diego's uh black
population 6.6 percent I don't think
that that aligns properly
no that's my point it's like it's low I
mean it's it's it's it's like half of
the national average
but
I don't think is it one of the top like
homicide cities San Diego actually has
lowest lower crime and for a while
exactly by Republican well yeah what
about not is it so so I mean perhaps the
argument is Democrats typically dominate
in the black vote and then Democrats
have garbage policies which result in
crime and releasing prisoners and things
like that you can I mean you can like I
heard you talking about this earlier Tim
the the fact that Rudy Giuliani went
into into New York City and cleaned it
up like that shows that it that right no
matter what the the racial population in
your city is because New York is you
know the it's as as mixed as it gets and
if you can go and have the right
policies and take New York City from you
know Skid Row to turning it into what is
essentially Disney World now or no five
years ago it's policy policies can solve
problems oh policy absolutely matters
and that's why I said it wasn't linear I
just said there's you know other factors
that probably correlate more I mean for
example New York City has I believe it
has more black people than like Chicago
does but Chicago is like way worse
obviously right that's why I don't I
don't know if it's the racial component
that aligns with the crime no no I'm not
saying that's the causal factor I said
it probably correlates more than having
a Democrat mayor ah
it feels too surface level to me right
if New York has more black people but
substantially less gun violence than
Chicago I don't see why you would draw
correlation between the racial makeup of
a city and be like Oh San Diego's got a
lower black population that explains the
crime rate I'm like no it doesn't no no
I'm saying because New York has a higher
block it's about does it correlate more
or less than having a Democrat mayor
yeah so so when we covered the story San
Diego had a Republican mayor and crime
was lower
okay New York has a lower black
population than Chicago and lower crime
than Chicago
so it's like I don't see the racial
connection I understand the point at the
surface level I guess if you were just
to look at it and be like oh hey look at
these things I mean so so what are the
states for example in the United States
that have like the lowest homicide rates
lowest yeah I don't know New Hampshire
Vermont very very low uh Idaho like I
mean
rural states with very few people and
there and there actually is a lot of
violent crime in say West Virginia where
people like to say oh the like one thing
they bring up is oh you know these
Democrat run seas are really bad it's
like it is true like when you when you
actually like we covered the story a
couple years ago when you look at the
top crime per capita as a correlation
between cities run by democrats with
higher crime than cities run by
Republicans but red States in general do
do have very high rates of violent crime
too sure I mean you can always parse the
statistics out in various ways for
example the gun control organizations
they'll always take
um they'll use gun deaths instead of gun
homicides and then that way they get the
statistics that they including suicide
well look all the Republican states
actually have higher rates of gun death
than the Democrats states do and then
they look at States they don't look at
municipalities and how those are run so
you know you can you can cherry pick it
any which way you want well so so here's
a question like why why are most major
cities Democrat no no hold on hold on
why are cities it's why are cities in
general Democrat in general yeah go to
West Virginia
go to any urban center no matter how
small it is for some reason Democrat
yeah I mean this is a global phenomenon
typically where like Urban centers tend
to be more uh left uh generally I think
when people congregate and they become
like sort of concentrated in certain
areas they uh they just think
differently they uh they don't have the
same day-to-day experiences people in
more rural areas historically so you
interact with your neighbor a lot more I
find you know what I mean because you
see your neighbor all the time you think
more about your neighbor I don't know if
that's correct in urban areas or rural
in urban areas for sure so I mean
because of that then you think when you
hear something saying oh well this is
better for all of us and hear the
flowery language things but if you feel
like people in urban areas interact with
your neighbor more than like people in
the in the suburbs yeah that's
completely right I think I don't know
but I feel like they ignore them
completely yeah totally see them in
person like seeing someone and actually
interacting with them is so different
it's different yeah we we've talked to a
certain degree with our neighbors out
here
in New York I lived above below side to
side and behind a person and I never saw
them never talked to them nobody
attracted them once totally I don't mean
interact I just mean like you see them
in person like you see the people that's
when you see the people not that you
maybe you didn't you didn't see them at
office I'm just I'm just trying to
speculate here and come up with
something I just I I think in cities you
know Luke uh radkowski made this video
10 years ago where he was he said you
know he goes on the subway all the time
and there's millions of people coming in
and out and they never once stop and
talk to each other so he decided one day
just to talk to them and ask them you
know and then he asked about conspiracy
theories and stuff it was kind of funny
but it's a good video but he makes a
good point yeah I think in cities they
don't talk to each other yeah I don't
mean I don't mean talk I mean like
literally just literally see them I
don't think that's the case I can't tell
you what my neighbors looked like I can
tell you all my neighbors out here look
like yeah like true to a certain degree
like we have to talk to him in the city
like I said I was in an apartment above
someone below someone had two apartments
to the side an apartment behind me it
was you got you got the the the the door
and there's a stairwell and then there's
apartments all around it totally and
then there's one corner corner and then
behind I don't I I I can't tell you what
they look like yeah true I mean you
definitely have more community in small
towns definitely because like that's
just reality you have to rely on your
community in a small town you're just
more likely to know who your cops are
right exactly I'm just trying to again
maybe that's some kind of Reason well
the the one thing about cities is is
cities do attract people that want to be
in cities like you hear the stories all
the time about kids that leave their
small town to go to the big city but
there there are kids that are like I
don't want to go to the big city I like
it like you definitely have temperaments
people that have a temperament that is
is more uh more conducive to wanting to
live in an urban area versus someone
that wants to live in a rural area and
then of course you do have a certain
amount of people that would go to a city
and be like this is not for me vice
versa but I think that the people that
that have the uh that are inclined to go
to cities and and seek out that kind of
Lifestyle probably have the same
inclination to be like oh I think that
the government should provide services
and and Etc things like that I don't
know I'm just trying to figure out like
like we asked like why is it that why is
the democrators do you have a do you
have a reason maybe well I'll tell you
this Democrat policy I think leads to
higher crime rates yeah and maybe it's
just
they're really good at scaring people
into falling in line and joining the
cult I guess yeah earlier about that how
it's a school to just go and vote
because everyone tells them to go when
you say you know there's a meteorologist
in New York Fox News got beaten up by a
bunch of teenagers yeah right in some
way yeah and they and the police said
we're not going to arrest or charge them
because they were 15 and 17 or whatever
well they said it would be a misdemeanor
and it's like how is it a misdemeanor
when this guy has like very visible
marks from being brutally assaulted
that's crazy because of their ages they
weren't charged they were released to
the parents so these are the policies
that Democrats enact uh look I get it
man I don't like cash bail I think we
need prison reform I think we need more
place accountability but like just
releasing criminals doesn't seem to make
sense no the the options that have been
brought you know the ideas that have
been have been brought up uh to deal
with the over criminalization maybe you
call it in the U.S they're not good
ideas like nobody like the idea of
getting rid of the police totally well
it's a terrible idea because they're
talking about replacing them with with
social workers that are completely and
totally incapable of securing an area to
try to deal with whatever's going on I
think part of it is like this idea like
with the meteorologists that well their
kids we don't want to mark them with
this records or listen to their parents
like I don't necessarily agree with that
but like there are a lot of places Rural
and not that try to prevent
children especially from being unfairly
punished for crimes that like if you
were an adult committed would be pretty
serious so like I wrote this article
last week about a 18 year old with the
age of 16 murdered four family members
in Cold Blood execution style in West
Virginia and he will be eligible he's
been given life in prison but because of
a mercy rule in West Virginia and
because he committed the crimes the
minor he's eligible for for parole in in
15 years
so is that because he deserves it is
that because his crime is Justified is
that because like at 16 he doesn't
understand the consequences like you're
saying these kids are 15 and 17. if you
got caught shoplifting I could see
releasing to your parents if you leave
physical marks on someone like you can
see that that crime is more serious but
I think you sell it like if you're
someone who lives in an area that is
affected by crime rural or not being
able to say like
yeah this person uh when you when you
get a criminal record at an early age
and it follows you for the rest of life
you are basically on a downward spiral
like it's very difficult to overcome
that I think we understand why this
stuff sells but in practical application
it doesn't always
serve the communities the best and to
really understand the differences
between major cities is hard because we
don't have a great example of a direct
comparison a city that has high violence
and is run by a Republican mayor and a
city that has high value similar
population run by democrats yeah now
think about Montreal for instance
because they're extremely racially and
ethnically diverse and they don't have
nearly the level of crime of Chicago
like what is wrong with Chicago true I
think it's the corruption I think
Chicago is a mob town you know a lot of
people are talking about the gang
bangers and all that stuff and and and
like the south side and the black
community and I'm like yeah no I hear
you man because I grew up down there but
you gotta understand the cops are
crooked as they come the cops would
kidnap and torture people when I was
like in my lifetime you know what I mean
so it's like the crime exists it just
exists in different ways something's
going on in Chicago where everybody's
just kind of a dick like not not
everybody obviously you know I love my
Chicago family but um a lot of a lot of
bad stuff like just think about all the
the in the early 1900s go to go to
Midlothian Turnpike if you want to see
where apparently that's where Capone
dumped all the bodies so you've had a
history of corrupt government the past
few Governors all going to prison you
have gang violence sums up with Chicago
I mean Baltimore is really bad too don't
be wrong Baltimore has a lot of crime
and uh so people want to look at the
surface level and they see a racial
component I assume there's a lot of
crime or there's corruption in Baltimore
but it doesn't I don't have the same uh
the same association with corruption
that I do with with Chicago for sure
Chicago you think you think the racial
component plays like no role whatsoever
I mean clearly we know that like it's a
surface level thing well you don't you
don't think there's like a big
difference as far as like different
groups the way they like commit homicide
like the amounts and like the rates I
don't think the race is the issue I'm
not saying I'm just saying like it's not
about it the race itself being the issue
it's that like the the actual it's just
the fact that this group has a higher
rate of homicide sure sure yeah and then
you you take into consideration
different societal factors
it's H2 like no no one is saying like 70
year old uh you know black people are
committing homicides at the same rate as
like 15 or like like 20 year old
Hispanic people like absolutely not the
the challenge is you obviously have I
did I I did a documentary I talk about
it periodically about Pruitt iGo
Ferguson the riots why people are so
angry why there's crime the way it is
and what ends up happening is I'll have
a conversation with someone and they'll
say exactly what you did they'll be like
oh but yeah but you know young black men
are the most are the high the higher
highest demographic when it comes to
murder and stuff and it's like in
Chicago it's very different in New York
New York has a much much lower crime
rate though the crime still does exist
but no but that that difference still
exists there as well right right and so
what it is is this is the challenge of
racism
is that people will will be like I'm
trying to figure out a pattern here and
I've noticed these two people look
different so I had a conversation with a
guy about uh race realism and he was
mentioning oh well you know Somalians
have low IQs and I was like Somalia a
country in in decades of Civil War and
strife and famine and drought and
constant you know like you're you're
well yeah but and then they would make
the argument that even people who've
left and I'm like right dude look you go
back three generations of a country
being destroyed or or people coming from
a place where there's limited nutrients
you're going to have that go down the
line genetics epigenetics or whatever I
don't think that we're solving the
problem by comparing a black guy from
Haiti to you know a black guy from the
South Bronx I think there's you can
probably I think there's genetic nature
versus nurture components and everything
so there's there's probably something to
be said for looking at an individual and
making determination like if you were to
say white people tend to be taller I'd
say Yeah in Scandinavia if you were to
say Asian people tend to be shorter I'd
be like right we know these things exist
but I don't think when we're trying to
get to the root of social problems it's
solved by being like well I happen to
notice the racial components in crime
and I'm like yeah and I also noticed the
voting patterns and I also noticed
they're releasing people from prisons in
these cities and so I kind of feel like
I understand there's a nature versus
nurture argument I kind of think it's in
the middle I think if we're actually
going to solve these problems we need to
just calmly say you know I don't think
the surface level racial component is
actually the the a strong enough
correlation or the cause of the problem
I think it could be solved if we didn't
have lunatic leftist policy but why do
you think it is that in New York City
for example when it comes to the
shootings and the murders it's almost
always every year over 93 percent uh
Black and Hispanic oh man this is a much
longer conversation we should probably
have in the members only because it's
going to take sure like we're seven
minutes past uh the doing super chats
but I think a large component obviously
has to do with why is it that Nigerian
immigrants don't have these levels of
crime and are very successful with
higher salaries but people born in
America who are black we notice these
Trends I think it might have something
to do with slavery the history of of
racial politics in this country I think
that you said you mentioned racial
politics I think that the the whole idea
of like uh young black people that that
study hard and they get told they're
acting white I think there's a stigma
that go that or at least I hear there's
a stigma in the black community about
let's try to Excel and they get told oh
you're acting white and blah blah so
it's probably something that's we gotta
go we gotta go super chats but we'll
we'll talk about this we'll get into a
lot more of the stuff in the members
only show
um not to say that I would talk about on
YouTube it's just that we're seven
minutes past when we like to start and
do super chats and get to people
questions so go to timcast.com become a
member smash that like button click that
join us button at timcast.com and then
we'll carry on this conversation and
we'll go into great detail as calmly and
reasonably as we want of course look man
there's a lot of people who just don't
care about any arguments and I I I'm not
a fan of I'm not a fan of any argument
that is tribal purely you can't convince
me I won't listen to you okay dude then
we're not having a conversation if you
want to have a conversation hang out
with us at timcast.com we may disagree
but that's that's the point all right
let's read uh let's read a bunch of
angry people who are fans of the
quartering one pissed off hippie says
became a member because I believed in
what you were doing after watching you
ignore the quartering situation makes me
wish I bought coffee instead we'll go
buy coffee dude I have no idea what
you're talking about I know something
vaguely having to do with the quartering
and Eliza blue I don't follow that I
don't do drama the quartering was
scheduled to come on the show next week
he canceled on us I have no idea why I
don't deal with booking there you go
yeah
Smokey Joe says you should hire Justin
Roiland to make a gric and smarty
cartoon done
big fan Justin Roiland let me know when
you want to make your uh Rick and Morty
all right Society remastered says happy
episode 700 thank you for all your hard
work and discipline over these years
also the Doomsday Clock is straight up
emotional abuse
yeah I realize it reminds me of uh
Threat Level Midnight but at The Office
episode
I mean it's it's the same thing as the
uh what was the color-coded terror alert
that we had for yeah yeah for the fire
one too we don't care what one fire one
I'm just kidding they have like the
smoking oh yeah yeah okay okay we asked
this so I mean yeah that's exactly what
it is it's just it's just a way to get
people to be anxious Victor papadopoula
says Nuance Bros video about the blue
Anon version of Tim pool AKA Dash
dubrovsky was Next Level hilarious this
super chat's for you bro yeah Dash de
bruh you know some people think I killed
him because like he doesn't do those
videos anymore on Twitter where he's
like oh boy big news he doesn't do
anymore not on Twitter that's the worst
news a lot uh calmer after the video
came out so oh wow yeah he had a whole
background like his whole life he was
like in Hollywood stuff like he was like
on Jay Leno Show when he was like a
little kid really yeah it was a very end
he had a whole show like dude he used to
not actually be like a terrible looking
kid and he was like dating hotties it
was it was very bizarre you've invited
him on the show I think
oh boy but they they like all of them
they just refuse to do it yeah I figure
yeah yeah that guy he does the videos
where he puts the camera right up in his
face as close as possible and then he
looks past the lens and not into the
lens you know what I mean yeah so it's
like the eyes look like they're going
through you and then he just keeps his
eyes wide and just goes for it you know
creepy all right where are we at Raymond
g Stanley Jr says Tim when the
apocalypse comes and you're shunned at
the gate for lack of trade skills we're
not good sir I'll let you into the side
door teamwork yeah I was basically
saying like dude if the apocalypse
happens I really doubt any like
emergency quarantine zone is going to be
like hey that's Tim pool we really could
use a guy who complains about stuff come
come in here and we'll give you our food
they're gonna be like bro can you chop
wood or not I'll be like I'll figure it
out man give me food are you bringing
your chickens with you that's well
that's the thing I got chickens they're
gonna come to me and be like bro we want
chickens and I'll be like you have to
listen to me complain
and you gotta do work
oh man Cody Justin Fender says come on
Tim free the quartering was the
quartering banned from YouTube or
something no I just looked at Twitter
and I saw him on Twitter I don't know if
it was YouTube no he's locked out of
Twitter because he he won't delete the
tweet that they're locking him out of
the account for oh I see dealt with the
Eliza blue well and you personally can
free him Tim I didn't know that I'll
call Elon actually Luke's the one who
has to do that yeah
no but um uh we had the quartering book
for like a month apparently I have to do
that apparently I've got all the
connects so shout out Jeremy uh I just
found out earlier today that he canceled
on us and I don't know anything about it
I don't do booking I have no idea yeah
for real he has been on that by the way
guys he has been on that thing for I
think over a month yeah yeah we booked a
long time ago we we booked him a while
back I can't remember exactly what
happened but we were gonna have him come
out and then he said it was like too
short notice too fast something like
that happened and then I was like let us
know whenever you want to come out and
then I guess we booked a date for yeah
30th or whatever yeah but then I just
found out today he canceled so we had to
pull in the sub we had to try and
scramble to find somebody else we would
love to have Jeremy here we were gonna
talk coffee that was the point we wanted
to have him come out we were going to
talk about coffee but I know you know
he's going through whatever he's going
through so uh you know best of luck man
I don't know Jeremy Jeremy's Jeremy's a
good dude hashtag unbanned brittanyventy
hashtag unban uh the quartering true all
right yeah but Trump says yes I lightly
smashed the clicker for the like button
I'm happy to see Phil again and glad
about him being more involved in the
show Hannah Claire is awesome I love her
so much look at that dang
see we were better recasting this is
like a better season of the show well it
will be back just kidding I'm just
kidding Ian's gonna be gone until Friday
night so he may be on the show Friday
night uh he brought bocus to an
experimental laboratory for stem cell
therapy it's actually it's interesting
because they can do bilateral uh
bilateral kidney transplants for cats
that are ridiculously expensive this
stem cell treatment is actually cheap
they harvest his own stem cells from his
blood and fat then they put him into his
blood and it will help his organs and
his damaged kidneys there's no guarantee
it saves his life because it's
experimental but they like what we know
about stem cell therapy they they're
they're confident and it's a couple
Grand I think so it's expensive but like
getting your cat a kidney transplant oh
man that's brutal yeah because I've had
people people were telling me that they
would spend 50 grand for one more day
with their cat and I'm like look man we
love Mr bocus he's a cat 50. but like 50
Grand hires a person to go you know
cover an important story and and help
Humanity like I don't want to let the
cat die but there's also like blend it
man and its surgery is not nothing right
like your cat would go under anesthesia
which is hard on them like you have to
weigh all of them well that's why he's
that's that that's the main reason he's
not getting it is because he wouldn't
survive it yeah they told us that
because of his conditions he wouldn't
survive a kidney transplant anyway so
good luck they said he might have a week
left he might have six months we have no
idea so we've been giving him
intravenous fluids and a hormone to
generate red blood cells which seems to
have given him life again because before
he was staggering around falling over
the red he was anemic the red blood cell
hormone treatment I guess brought him
back but he barely eats he's getting
thinner and thinner and thinner and he's
getting and nothing reverses kidney
failure I mean other than maybe stencils
but before that there wasn't but right
so we don't they think the stem cells
will we're not 100 sure
we watched a video in the members only
section before about stem cell therapy
sounds like it might they don't know any
impressive stuff did he have to qualify
like were there any obligations you had
to have certain like blood levels and
medical stuff and they said he qualifies
he has to get medication they put him
under anesthesia they harvest stem cells
they inject them and then
we'll see what happens man yeah we'll
see what happens
yeah the sad thing is
um the doctor said they don't think it's
anything that could have been averted he
was a street cat he has a bad heart he
has bad kidneys they're underdeveloped
this is what happens with Street Cats
you rescue and uh it's a bummer do you
have any pets yeah man no no no
all right let's see
let's grab one OMG puppy says outside
the U.S media bubble the world is not
worried about Russia starting nuclear
war they're worried about America
starting nuclear war with their neocon
when their neocon plans don't work yeah
I hear that man yeah I hear that don't
worry we're we're worried about that as
well that's right
Mavis says according to Canadian prepper
there's a Russian ship or sub off the
east coast and off of the coast of
Hawaii they're poised to strike at any
time
that's I believe it that's likely yeah
we had someone Super Chat saying that
there are they they work on a sub and
they do patrols because you got to go
around try and find them from a sub when
they're not on patrol yeah you can't
send signals like that from sub from uh
submarines at certain depths I guess
they don't have 5G down there so I don't
know the exact depth but uh different
frequencies can't penetrate water is
this starlink no yeah so like the best
the best radiation Shield I think it is
for for uh shuttles and space stuff
water they have water line uh because
water diffuses radiation yes interesting
thing uh I learned that when I was
trying to create a water drum went back
in the early days 12 years ago we were
doing a bunch of drone work and we had
ground drones remote control cars air
drones water drones and the problem with
water drones is you can't get signal
underwater so they have to be connected
but they do have these really cool thing
they're it's a fish and it swims around
it's like autonomous and it scans holes
and stuff and sends data back it's
really cool stuff
yeah and then I had this little I had
this uh this is amazing I had this
little remote control two-wheeled car
with a camera on it that I would bring
with me when I would do field work field
reporting because what we would do is if
we were at a point where there was like
a police line and you couldn't go past
it we would I would take it off my bag
pop its Wheels out turn it on and then
just Chuck it because it bounces and
then we take your phone you take your
phone app and you drive it through and
you can film what's going on yeah and
then we also had the I had the the air
drone on my backpack that I could take
off put it down launch with the computer
and then live stream what it was showing
we only did a couple times but the idea
was like Hey man
I'm allowed to drive my little remote
control car it's got it at a range of a
couple hundred feet and it could go
around corners and so if I'm like not
only that if there's like active riding
and molotovs I'll send in the little car
to film so you can see what's going on
oh true that was fun that's so cool yeah
you know the thing is like nobody really
does it anymore
I was just me and my friends were doing
the weird hacker stuff on the ground
most people just don't even live stream
at all
right Brandon hamson says Tim the clock
has 90 seconds now but you're forgetting
about daylight savings time once March
hits the world ends good point great
yeah
all right let's see what we got we'll
grab some more Super chats why do they
pick out like it's a clock with no
specific date yeah it's the anxiety
clock yeah be anxious yeah tablet link
says top secret material is largely a
joke these days I was forced to subvert
clearance as a teenager to work on
Blackhawks as a contractor TS pages in
The manuals for mundane equipment and
full print on iff and secure Radio
Systems
interesting over classification yeah
Sterling Wilson III says guys who thinks
they're running for president in 24.
it's pretty simple the Deep state is
willing to burn all of the olds and have
a coastal presidential Face-Off CA
versus Florida
Newsome versus DeSantis that doesn't
doesn't sound perfect about Bolton he's
he's in the race
Nikki Haley is almost certainly jumping
into the nuclear war and uh what's her
name Christina Elm seems to be
positioned DeSantis vs gnome seems to
make a lot of sense in the Nintendo's
wins uh let's see brown bear says Tim
look up the Jason Harley shooting guy
got blasted by SWAT when he opened his
door and now they're trying to charge
him with a bunch of bunk I saw the video
yeah it's crazy man
yeah that's the video where he walks to
the door the camera's in it and he opens
it and he's his hands out and they start
shooting him and then the cops come in
and say oh F yeah and they released a
statement saying he came out yelling
he's in confrontation yeah just total
criminal charges Man Cherokee County
North Carolina lock him up they have
their judges there should absolutely be
criminal charges for that absolutely
and I think that there had been another
big officer involved shooting in the
same county like a month before a bunch
of officers if you watch the video the
reason that he got shot is because he
opened the door he had their drone they
threw a drone into his house in the
middle of the night like a flying one
like no just a little roller one and you
like you know you can see on the camera
it rolls around or whatever
what the heck is this what's going on he
walks out to the door with the Drone in
his hand and opens the door like this
puts his hands up and he's got the Drone
in his hand but even still his hands are
in the air right like he's not pointing
at anything your hands are up you
shouldn't you should never ever ever
have anything in your hands when you
popped around absolutely I understand
that but still his hands at this point
he's in a submitting don't give him an
excuse no never give him an excuse at
this point what I would do is just lay
on the ground spread my legs and arms
and I'm not moving no matter what a cop
says because you remember that video
where the cop walks in and he's like
crawl to me grow oh yeah like Simon Says
knock your hands up now glad down and
then what happened was the guy's
crawling and his pants are falling down
he goes to pull his pants up and then he
just unloads on him and kills him I'm
like bro should have just laid there and
spread his arms and legs out as wide as
possible and then just not done anything
and that's not a word not done a thing
that poor dude was drunk too he had he
was he was he'd been he had a pumpkin
all day what he had a pestic gun he had
a pellet gun for A Pest Removal oh is
that what he had and someone saw it
through the window so they called the
place that a man was waving on a gun
which he wasn't so they showed up he has
no idea what's happening and he's
screaming at him he had his shirt off
and he just had sweatpants on his
sweatpants were falling down he went to
grab them and pull them up I think he's
running a shot but he was crawling and
his pants fell down and he pulled it up
and I mean to be honest the cop should
have shot him but to the cop he sees a
guy's reaching for his belt a guy who's
reportedly has a gun either way though
it's like dude if you're that scared
yeah you should be a cop yeah 100
apparently that guy got rehired or
something it's atrocious yeah Michael
teal says Rand Paul today said the
amount of things listed as classified as
absurd the food menu at the White House
is classified that would actually make
sense to me though
at the White House they're serving
braised short rib with mashed potatoes
and bread with truffle butter
and someone is trying to cause harm to
government officials and they need to
know if they're going to taint food what
that food will be it makes sense to
classify that food so that no one can
figure out what fake food to send in I
get that but if you here now oh the
classified documents they find at Mike
Pence's house is actually a menu from a
state dinner that someone in his family
kept is that still the same precaution I
would get it for active presidential you
know issues but like if it's like a
piece of their scrapbook like I don't
know that we're all should they remain
classified like the menu should it
remain classified in perpetuity or like
doesn't make sense someone released the
menu from six weeks ago well and
occasionally the one I was like for say
dinners and stuff they'll release the
menu before like there's this big thing
where they were like uh when they had
Emmanuel macron in town they're like
here's all this stuff including this
salmon or this Lobster from Maine right
after Biden had like passed or allowed
all of these restrictions to be placed
on the main lobster industry and the
entire main Congressional Delegation was
like um could you please meet with us
immediately if you're gonna serve Maine
Lobsters you should at least be not
strangleholding the industry and as far
as I know he is still not met with the
main Congressional Delegation yeah I'm
not surprised Maine is like a multi I
think it's a 1.2 billion dollar industry
in Maine wow yeah Denise Anne says
Robert Barnes thinks Demar died and
they'll reveal it after SB Super Bowl I
wouldn't put it past them NFL wants to
be relevant no not gonna happen isn't
Barnes also the guy who said that
Trump's gonna pick DeSantis as his VP
and the deal's been made he says a lot
of things yeah like come on guys I'm not
saying this about Barnes whatever I'll
say this in general if you think after
the Super Bowl they'll come out and
announce actually Demar died and that
wasn't him or at the very least yes he's
dead
that is just movie level stuff that
doesn't happen to be fair I guess this
this season you know could potentially
be crazier than the past the writers for
the simulation have been kind of going
off the rails so I you know maybe but I
just I'm not gonna I'm not I wouldn't
put chips on it what would the sorry I
don't understand football I would like
to very much but what does the Super
Bowl have to do the timing just like
that's the big question
like why why not wait until next season
why not wait until like why why wait
until the Super Bowl why just not say
anything why why not just keep this guy
around just say literally nothing and
then people will eventually forget about
him and then no one will ever have to
say anything about anything if he
actually died they can just do nothing
and then a year ago by whatever tomorrow
but he retired
yeah yeah hard thing crazy what's he
doing now family yeah why is it why why
isn't he in the Press yeah well he's not
playing football
yeah yeah so he's not in the Press
anymore no he's not playing football
sorry have a nice day
why not I I just I just I don't know I
don't know that guy was they haven't
proved it was him but I don't know if
they're gonna come out back he's
actually dead
I mean okay what is this well there you
go we are changing the chat says I
didn't do this do what you left bro
you know you trying to trying to opine
here on this show you're not even not
even mad at you we're gonna get Sheamus
we miss you Luke Sheamus where everybody
tweeted Sheamus tell Sheamus to come
back because Luke abandoned us yeah Phil
we're not good enough Replacements over
here yeah you know so basically Luke
breaks up with the show so we go
crawling back to Sheamus
I've been texting Sheamus for months
telling him to get back out here he
talks a lot about on the internet about
one or on Twitter about wanting to come
back just needs to do it she doesn't do
it Sheamus I messed up I said Sheamus we
miss you come back we want you on the
show and he was like you know figure it
out I'm like he hates us
no I'm kidding Sheamus doesn't hate us
Sheamus has got you know his own company
and the same thing with Luke like you
know Luke and James both run their own
company so they have to do their own
stuff and then they come on the show I'm
sure actual Justice Warrior is totally
willing to to come here and be a co-host
didn't we we had him on the show before
I know we should bring him on as a
regular host why not oh I mean he can
come you know I had to give him at least
one shout out during the show did he pay
you no I always you know I I had to he's
a good friend so
says Justin Roiland was a proponent of
me too cancel culture now he's getting
canceled years later for domestic
charges and leaked questionable private
messages look into it let them eat their
own was he approved was he was he Pro
canceled culture really I think I don't
know if he was well then you know
but here's my attitude anybody who
apologizes I'll say you know welcome so
if Justin Roiland came out I was like
look I was wrong about that stuff guys
please I desperately need help they're
destroying my life I'd be like okay I
got you bro I think Rick and Morty's
funny he's made a lot of funny jokes I
love the joke where they did I think it
was like season four or something where
he's in his own brain and he's being
interrogated by the aliens and then he's
he's having a memory he's like oh no
this is the time he's like the worst
member of my life when 9 11 happened and
then like in the background you hear him
you hear him very quietly go they're
going to use it as a pretext for taking
away our freedoms like he's got good
jokes man I like it I love the pickle
Rick one when uh when he's like I turned
myself into a pickle Morty and he's like
and he goes and and what you want me to
say 911 was an inside job or something
that was good
yeah he does a good job this season was
okay you know everything was kind of
kind of wonky with kova and everything
in the past couple Seasons but there
were a few seasons are they on it's been
six I think yeah yeah it's been a decade
yeah six seasons a decade man you got to
make your show uh faster
yeah two cents Lupa Lopez says check
with Tom fitton Judicial Watch he sued
Obama for having classified documents
and lost in court they said president
can declassify does Crowder want to
destroy daily wire what's his end goal I
don't know what Crowder's end goal is I
mean I think my view of crowder is that
uh
he
my opinion is that he views the rumble
locals model where an individual retains
their subscribers as like a better way
to do things because like even they made
the point I actually I think the only
real concern he has is I think they were
saying don't claim you're fighting big
Tech when you outright outlining your
contracts that people have to be on big
Tech because that doesn't seem like
legitimate like honest so I don't know
whatever
I don't think he wants to destroy
anything I think he wants things to be
different he brought up the Obama
classification thing
who did and then the Super Chat for the
time yeah because I think the the thing
with the Obama in the classified
documents is that they're in the hands
of like the National Archives like the
National Archives manages the classified
documents for Obama even though they're
like what they're like Presidential
Library or something like that I don't
know but I don't think that was what
people were making it out to be hmm
all right let's see
David Turman says great meeting you and
Phil at Freedom Plaza if you do another
event when it warms up I'll bring a
whole battery-powered band to play while
you skate uh yeah probably and we're
doing it we're doing a live event at the
Vulcan in Austin I think it's in April
in April yeah I don't have the link or
anything ready but apparently it's up
you can they can buy tickets now can't
they I think so yeah yeah well there you
go so it's the Vulcan yeah Alex Stein's
gonna be there Alex Jones Michael Mouse
Blair white Luke Rakowski uh maybe a
handful of other people we're gonna
we're gonna have a blast down there in
Austin we're gonna be doing the show uh
live from Austin for the week it's gonna
be a lot of fun right and uh maybe some
other guests and then the day after so I
think it's Friday Tim cast IRL live and
then Saturday is the minds event so
we're like not the events aren't in
conjunction but like you know we planned
it because we're friends with Minds so
we do our think Friday night and then
the next day you have the whole Minds
event so it's going to be a blast it's
going to be a great weekend and then
I'll of course be I I don't think I'm I
don't know if I'm officially at the
minds thing in some I don't note the
official capacity is that I'll be there
but I'll be there I don't know if they
put me on a panel or something I think
you're listed on the actual thing I mean
I'm there we're hanging out we're doing
a party and stuff something I don't know
I'm you know we're all friends we're all
doing this but it's like Friday night we
do our thing and then the next day is
the big mines I think it's gonna be a
whole awesome what is this
April okay what is it do you guys are
the 14th the 15th yeah that's correct
14th yeah 14th the 15th is the minds
thing okay you're gonna be there if you
uh absolutely cool yeah we're gonna
we're gonna figure my birthday the 15th
oh so nice of mine's three apart yeah
we'll get a we'll bring a cake and
we'll just grab a couple more here
Ronald pant says not overclassified it's
called opsec look it up and look up how
that and Tom Clancy and pows in Vietnam
are related interesting all right last
one Shane Marley says both of them are
much better guests than Sheamus because
they Don't Preach bible stuff to me well
you know I actually like that about
Sheamus I thought it was interesting to
have uh you know we don't have staunchly
uh religious individuals as often with
Sheamus it created a different
perspective you don't often hear
nothing's valuable you know Ian's the
graphene guy he's everyone's got their
quirks Luke's the the parks departments
are communist he's like we have our cast
of characters with their with their you
know Specialties speaking about uh he
mentioned religion just today uh you
didn't talk about it but there was a
book released that Pope Benedict the
previous Pope not the current one passed
away he wrote it before uh he passed
away I mean obviously but he wanted to
release after he passed away because of
the stuff that he said essentially the
Catholic church has been the whole
Vatican has been overtaken by like
Liberation theology which is the
basically Marxist Catholicism
essentially the whole cat Holy Roman
Catholic church has fallen to the
Antichrist like if you're a Catholic
essentially where are you I think
Sheamus talks about this actually yeah
Sheamus tell people the Catholic church
has fallen to the Antichrist all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com click that join us button
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show not so family friendly
coming up we post them about 11 p.m I
got through that very quickly just for
you guys uh smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
Nuance bro do you want to shout anything
out yeah uh follow me Nuance bro on
Twitter Youtube Instagram all that good
stuff and uh yeah thanks for having me
on anytime brother awesome yeah yeah
we'll bring you in actual Justice work
on at the same time so if you guys that
sounds awesome I would like to meet Sean
yeah it's good people I think of stuff
good people I'm here Claire I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should follow
timcast news on Twitter it's where you
can see work from me and all the rest of
our journalists uh you can follow me on
Instagram at Hannah clara.b you can
follow me on Twitter at HC brimelow and
yeah thanks you guys for having me yeah
I'm Phil that remains follow me on
Twitter uh I'm Philip remains official
on Instagram the band is called All That
Remains we're heavy metal and we will
kick you in the privates
and uh I am atsearch.com it's good to be
back guys uh that was a fun one right on
someone mentioned that Tim guest is not
on the Vulcan website that I see
I don't know we got the link or
something we'll figure it out and we'll
get it up soon so uh and then and then
we'll share it and we'll have it on all
the posts you can buy tickets and I
don't know how many seats is it a couple
hundred or something I think it's a
couple hundred
um so you should you should you should
get your tickets early it's really for
sure all right everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out